von
Pock
So
Huge Pock
Omega Pock
Ich kann mal gucken
Ist der Frasier an
Nö
Ich bin da
So
überhaupt nicht mehr so YouTube
Can't wait
Der Titel des Videos ist überhaupt nicht mehr so
Ich hab das umgehängt, was war die beste
Gaming Zeit, falls es besser trifft
Was für ein Titel findet ihr besser?
Spiele waren früher nicht besser
Ok, Boomer, oder was war die beste
Gaming Zeit? Und habt ihr noch einen besseren
Vorschlag für den Titel? Gibt's irgendwie
Big Brain Titel? Titel
Brains im Chat
Ok, der Chat
Die Leute kommen erst rein, ja
Der Titel ist
Gar nicht mehr so ok
Spiele waren schon immer
Scheiße
Dann müssten wir es komplett
Clickbait machen
Du glaubst nicht
Welche
Ich kann keine Clickbait Titel machen
Gescheit, Leute, ich bin nicht in der Lage
Aber zumindest eine Sache, was man echt wieder sieht
Was ich nie gedacht hätte
Die Videos, wo es um die Arbeit geht
Sind viel, viel
Beliebter
Als die Videos, wo es um Gaming geht
Ohne Scheiß
Hier, wenn ich Videos mache
Über Stellangebote, Server, der was
Kaputt macht, Berufsschule
Überflüssig
Alles wird total viel geguckt
Mach ich Video über Gaming, bam, interessiert keinen mehr
Die Zeiten haben sich so krass geändert
Wir sind alle alt geworden
Ist echt so
Also wie gesagt
Vielleicht ist auch der
Vielleicht ist auch der Titel einfach nicht gut
Das geht, glaube ich
Vielleicht ist auch der Titel nicht gut
Ich brauch da noch einen besseren Titel
Für Spiele waren früher
Nicht besser, ok, Boomer
Ich kann es mal probieren
Ich kann den ändern, vielleicht, ne
Warum deine Lieblingsspiele
Nicht gut sind, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt
Ok, das hat ja nicht wirklich mit dem Inhalt zu tun
Aber, gut, ich meine
Ich muss es ja auch nicht in der heutigen Zeit, ne
Ach, ich hab keine Ahnung
Ist auch wurscht
Heute spielen wir was anderes, nämlich einen Half-Life Mod
Und zwar wir spielen heute Half-Life
Echoes
Hab ich gesehen
Das ist ein relativ neuer Mod
Der wurde erst geupdatet vor ungefähr einem Jahr
Und war, glaube ich, Mod des Jahres 2018
Und ihr wisst ja
Waren Spiele früher besser liegen, mein Nacktes
Ja, ok, da mach ich auf jeden Fall
Ein Huge Chebat raus
Also da mach ich auf jeden Fall ein Huge Chebat raus
Wenn ich meinen 3D-Kicks auf Fiverr hab, Leute
Der 3D-Kicks auf Fiverr
Dann mach ich so ein Thumbnail
Mit so einer Silhouette
In schwarz
Und dann kommt in dem Video der redende Kicks dabei
Und dann muss ich
Und dann spiel ich folgendes
Am Anfang, wenn ich das Video starte
Was Mod des Jahres nicht?
Sebaro
Doch doch, aber
Ich weiß nicht
Die Antwort war echt gut, da weiß ich jetzt nicht, was ich drauf sagen soll
Sebaro
Ist Cute Mod des Jahres
Oder des Jahrzehnts
Wobei meine anderen Mods
Sind ja auch alle Pock
Sebaro ist
Der Sebaro kann auf jeden Fall nicht Mod des Jahres 2021 werden
Weil dafür ist er zu wenig da
Da kann er aber nichts dafür
Weil da muss ja Studierungsstells
Und Lehramtsgrill
Bezirzen machen
Der hat keine Zeit
Für
Wie der Clickbait
Ja ich brauch einen guten Titel, ohne Scheiß
Wo würde man
Mehr draufklicken?
Spiele waren früher nicht besser, ok Boomer
Ich finde der hier trifft es eigentlich
Vom Video her
Ich hab da keine Emojis drin
Das wird sein, ich muss da Emojis rein machen, Leute
Zack
Eingeloggt auf dem zweiten Rechner
Da müssen Emojis rein, jetzt weiß ich
Woran das liegt
Keine Emojis im Titel
Verloren
Fragezeichen Emoji, ok
Zack, das mach ich jetzt, get
Question
Ich weiß, dass ich das nicht kopieren muss, ich kann einfach
Auch hier drücken, ich kenn das
Question
Das da, oder das Rote
Was ist besser, oder beide, beide
Beide
Du musst die Sternchen benutzen
Warum, welche Sternchen
Ok
Moment, jetzt hab ich schon mal aktualisiert
Gucken wir mal ob das jetzt besser ist
Der Titel
Ist es jetzt besser?
Die beste
Aha
Ist das so, muss man das so machen?
Das heißt ich muss so machen
Moment, Moment
Ich lerne, ich lerne ja noch was
Richtiges Titel Baiting angeht
Also so
So
Ist das jetzt schon, ist das jetzt schon besser
Also geht das, geht das jetzt
Heute das YouTube, das aktuelle
YouTube Game
Ja, ist das, hab ich das abgesteppt
Viel ansprechender
Ok, ok
Was können wir mit dem Titel sonst noch machen?
Ist nicht
War das die beste Gaming Zeit?
Doch, da hast du recht
War
Und dann das große
War das die beste
Gaming Zeit?
Ok, ok
So jetzt
Oder das klein
Das ist, das ist
Wer liest denn sowas, Alter
Das sieht ja aus
Das passt
Sagt dir, das ist
War das die beste
Gaming Zeit? Ok, easy, easy
Der Discord sollte mit Titeln beauftragt werden
Ok, was soll ich machen, Leute?
Also, das ist doch ok
Oder soll ich, aber das
Müsste ich eigentlich groß machen?
Warte mal, ich probier mal was
War das die beste
Ich mach mal die Sternchen weg
Das sieht zu beknackt aus
Titel wurde gern
War das
Gaming, ich kann Gaming
Oder soll ich Gaming klein machen?
So ist besser als Sternchen, oder?
Ey, Titeldiskussion
Das ist ne super Idee
Ich bin da total unkreativ immer
Du musst noch
Die Font ändern
Was ist das?
Aber warum bedoppel es?
Was war der ursprüngliche Titel?
Was war die beste?
Ja, ich lass das jetzt so
Ich muss die Schrift noch ändern
Oder?
Ok, Moment
Der erste war besser?
Was war der erste?
Was war die beste Gaming-Zeit?
Oh, Big Brain, Math Bold Italic
Ja, Moment
Wenn man das fett machen kann, ist er noch besser
Moment, Moment, Moment
Was sagt ihr dazu?
Leute, was sagt ihr dazu?
Spiele waren früher nicht besser
Ok, Boomer
Der war besser?
Ey, Alter
Das sieht aus wie bei Katja Krasavice
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob die noch Videos macht
Das sieht dumm aus
Ja, ja
Das ist schon seriöser so, ja
Was haben die sonst noch?
Oh ja, das da, das natürlich
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob die noch lebt
Das ist mir auch vollkommen wurscht
Ich denke mal, dass die noch lebt
Nein, ich will schon, dass das was mit dem Inhalt zu tun hat
Ok, nice
Also jetzt haben wir uns um den Videotitel gekümmert
Wie von Zulul
Ok, jetzt sind ja die Leute da
Jetzt mal generell, welchen Titel fandet ihr besser?
Den Titel?
Spiele waren früher nicht besser
Ok, Boomer, da ist mir nichts anderes eingefallen
Und jetzt den Titel
Ich finde den Titel schon passender
Wir machen mal kurz
Den ersten
Ok, wir machen kurz Umfrage
Wir machen kurz Umfrage
Welcher Videotitel war besser?
So
Oder
Hallo
Ja, das ist die abgekürzte Geschichte
Ihr wisst welches ich meine
Den Titel oder
Oder den Titel
Jetzt machen wir die Umfrage ab
Also wie gesagt
Ihr wisst welches ich meine
Den Titel oder eben den Titel
Das kann ich leider nicht mehr reinkopieren
Was war die beste Gaming-Spiele?
Waren früher nicht
Nicht
Ja
Schauen wir mal
Lassen wir noch eine halbe Minute laufen
Dann ist Mod-Time
Aus dem Ok, Boomer
Könntest du eine ganze Videoreihe machen
Ja, das stimmt eigentlich
So nach dem Motto
Die sich immer so eine Frage stellen
Was ich auch beispielsweise
Gut machen könnte ist
Gaming ist jetzt Mainstream
Oder Gaming
Gaming ist Mainstream
Und jetzt Fragezeichen
Ok Boomer, da könnte man echt so eine Reihe draus machen
Das ist wirklich eine gute Idee
Was hältst du von XFCE?
Kann man benutzen, ist ok
Ok wunderbar
Exzellent, passt
Ich lasse es jetzt einfach so
Was war
Die beste
Moment, ich muss mir das noch mal angucken
Wie sah das so aus?
Zack
Ich finde das ist auch cool
Weil es ist
Komm scheiß drauf, ich lasse es jetzt einfach so
Ok Leute, Chat
Confirmed, Confirmed der Chat
Da können wir jetzt nämlich anfangen
Ok Boomer
Staffel 1
Warum Gaming in Caps
Weil es darum letztendlich geht
Soll ich
Soll ich mal ohne Caps probieren
Meinst du
Das ist der Fokus auf beste
Die Sternchen sind doof
Ne, das ist doof
Das muss, muss
Ok, so
Ich lasse es jetzt einfach, also
Wir spielen jetzt
Half Life Echoes
War
Ich glaube, was ich erzählt habe
Stimmt übrigens gar nicht, es war nicht
Mod des Jahres 2018, es war aber
Top 3 Mod des Jahres
Des Jahres 2018
Aber ist ja letztendlich auch egal
Zumindest ihr wisst, dass ich riesen
Half Life Fanboy bin, was man ja auch schon am aktuellen
Video sieht, weil das gleich
Insde erstmal Half Life Gameplay drin hat
Und das ist nicht allzu
Lang, ich glaube das geht
3 Stunden
Und
Es ist, es schließt wohl
Direkt an Half Life an
Ich hab's vorhin schon mal gestartet
Und geguckt, dass ich die
Die Zensur aus der deutschen Version
Raus mache, ihr kennt
Ja, deutsches Half Life hat ja diese
Ähm, Roboter
Soldaten und sowas, weil sich
Damals noch alle gefürchtet
Haben quasi Blut und Leute
So in deutschen Games rein zu machen
Ja, aber mittlerweile ist das alles okay
Jetzt habe ich
Die Zensur rausgemacht, ist vorhin gestartet
Also
Tja, keine Ahnung
Ich hab keinen Schimmer von dem Game
Großartig
So, und es schließt wohl direkt
An Half Life 1, also es läuft parallel
Zu Half Life 1
Und es gab ja im Original
Half Life, du hattest die Main Kampagne mit Gordon Freeman
Du hattest
Opposing Force mit
Shepard, wie ist der Typ?
Adrian Shepard, genau
Also der
Soldat
Und dann hattest du Blue Shift
Mit dem Wachmann
So, und das ist ein Mod
Da spielst du jetzt als Scientist
Die Events von Half Life 1
Aber wie gesagt
Geht nicht so lang
Vielleicht 2, 3 Stunden
Aber soll echt gut sein
So eine Mischung aus Half Life und
Horror-Stells
Mal gucken
Ich weiß nicht, ehrlich gesagt, inwieweit mich
Half Life 1 noch horren kann, weil
Die Graphics sind halt doch schon ein bisschen
Dated
Aber gucken wir mal
Gucken wir mal, so, starten wir mal
Bam, auf geht's
Müssen wir mal gucken, ob wir, oh, huge
Auflösung
Massive Auflösung haben wir hier am Start
Das ist ja
Hört ihr gerne mal auf, so groß ist die Auflösung
Das Bild hier vor allem ist richtig gut
Aufgelöst
So, erstmal kurz schauen, wie
Ist die Lautstärke eingestellt?
Das muss definitiv runter
Irgendwie auf sowas da
Das ist immer massig laut, die alten Games
Wir müssen gleich gucken
Wie die Lautstärke ist
Okay, Parameters, also Voice
Und
Wo ist das
Direkt X
Rendering?
Half Life hatte doch immer Direkt X Rendering
Wo ist das?
Hä?
Hatte das nicht? Moment
Half Life 1
Das hat
Garantiert, das weiß ich
Was?
Remove Direkt 3D Renderer
Warum?
Ah, wegen ihrer Linux
Support, okay, verstehe, alles gut
Dann verwenden wir jetzt eben
Den OpenGL Renderer, auch gut
Widescreen, wie gesagt, das ist
Kein Mod für Half Life 2
Das ist ein Half Life 1 Mod
So, wir müssen gleich gucken
Wie die Lautstärke ist, wenn ich das Game gestartet habe
Dann so
Wait, ist wie SYNC
Wir müssen übrigens
Oh, wir müssen unbedingt in einem Video
In einem Window runnen
Äh
Wait a minute
Wenn ich das
Im Window runne, sieht aber
Reutig aus
Ich hab ne Idee
Man kann auch die Tastleiste ausblenden, oder?
Auto Hide Taskbar
Moment, Auto
Auto Hide Taskbar, ging das?
Wo ist das unter Windows versteckt, Leute?
Ne, Alt Enter
Bringt nix, Alt Enter, das ist so ein
Alles Game, das kann das nicht
Aber ich brauch, ich brauch's im Fenster
Modus, sonst kann ich keine Meme Overlays machen
Das sind den Settings, Taskbar
Settings
Automatically Hide Task
Was?
Ein krasser
Chebat
Okay, wir müssen's Fullscreen machen
Keine Chance
Jetzt hab ich die Kacke
Warte mal
Okay, kann man nicht?
Half Life 1 Window
Mode
Border
Da gibt's doch bestimmt was
How can I
Play
Oh
Jetzt wird's Big Brain
You can set Game to run in borderless
Window through Steam
Set Launch Options, Windows
Borderless
Yes
In VM spielen?
Was? Warum?
Warum soll ich das in der VM spielen?
Okay, das müssen wir jetzt Steam machen
Wie macht man die Launch
Settings davon?
Wie macht
Leute, jetzt seid ihr gefragt
Wie macht man Launch Settings in Steam?
Macht man das überhaupt?
Properties?
Unten?
Wait a minute, wo?
Chat, helft mir
Da unten, unten Launch Properties
Ah
Advanced users may choose
To enter notifications
Und das speichert er jetzt einfach so?
Okay, schauen wir mal
Ist das jetzt bordert?
Nö
Einfach immer noch Fullscreen
Oder?
Das versteckt meine Memes
Was soll das hier?
Anzeige ist raus
Nö
Vielleicht muss ich jetzt hier Run
Window wegmachen
Nope
Ich hab das Game
neu gestartet, okay
Ähm
Nope, keine Chance
Wir werdens
ohne Memes und Care Quits überleben
Was natürlich schon ein bisschen doof ist, aber na gut
Hm
Keine Emotes einplanen
Literally unplayable
Ja, ist echt so
Aber wenn wir keine Emotes einplanen können, dann kann ich auch
Options wieder rausmachen
Ich muss
Musik ausmachen
Hallo
Wo ist jetzt?
Wait a minute
So, okay, jetzt legen wir los
Okay, Leute, es ist kaputt
Jetzt ist es broken af
Jetzt gehts
Ja, jetzt gehts
Okay, wunderbar, also
Parameters, äh, Audio
Hier volle Pulle, natürlich, was sonst
Sonst sieht man den Half-Life 1
Was?
Wait
Sieht man den Half-Life 1 nix
Äh, Voice Note Multiplayer
Keyboard
Quick Save auf F5
Sonst check ich nix
Okay, auf gehts
Begin observation
Wir spielen Schwer, oder?
Chat, was mein dir? Schwer
Muss
Oh, wir spielen auf Schwer
Proceed
Eats Pro
Nee, stimmt, wir spielen nicht auf Schwer
Wir spielen auf Stringent
Okay, und jetzt müssen wir gleich mal schauen, ob die
Lautstärke und so okay ist
Proceed
Sagt mir, ob die
Lautstärke so passt
Bissi leise, hä?
Tickenlauter können wir schon noch machen
Oh
Und?
Ich sag gleich was
Der G-Mann
Hat nichts mit der G-Mar zu tun
Oh, das war schlecht
Was ist Half-Life Echoes?
Ein Mod, wo man Half-Life 1
Zeit als Wissenschaftler
in Plank Mesa spielt
So, ich jump jetzt
ein bisschen rum und ihr sagt mir mal gleich, ob die Lautstärke
passt
Bissi leise
glaube ich, oder?
Ja
Freeman ist doch ein Wissenschaftler, ja
der zählt für mich aber nicht als
weißer Kittelwissenschaftler
Bissi leise? Bissi lauter?
Schauen wir mal
Ich kann keinen Bunny hoppen, richtig
Wir hören jetzt mal, wenn einer labert
Ich glaube, Lautstärke ist okay, oder?
Sagt mir mal
Bissi lauter, Bissi leiser, okay so
Passt
Du musst springen
aufs Mausrad packen
Eine Spur, ich glaube auch
ein Ticken, aber nicht viel
Wir machen einfach mal so hier
Wir haben 8, wir machen einfach mal 10
Das sollte gut passen
Ja
Das tut
Was geht?
Keiner redet mit mir
Nö
Ich war schon 20 Jahre nicht mehr hier
Die haben keine neuen Sounds
aufgenommen für das Game
Wäre ja auch schwierig gewesen
20 Jahre nachdem das Spiel rausgekommen ist
Die haben Sound-Samples verwendet, habe ich gelesen
aus
dem normalen Half-Life
Blue-Shift
Opposing Force, Half-Life 2
Episode 1, Episode 2
Die haben quasi alles an offiziellem Sound-Material genommen
und haben irgendwie geguckt, ob sie das da ein...
stelzen können
Echt mal gespannt
Dass ich springe ist übrigens
Hatte Half-Life 1 Dosenphysik?
Keine Dosenphysik
Hast du damals Blue-Shift
Opposing Force gespielt? Klar
Blue-Shift habe ich aber glaube ich nur einmal
durchgespielt, also Opposing Force mehrfach
Ich bin immer wieder begeistert
Wie viele Automaten in Black Mesa
rumstehen, an jeder Ecke steht so ein Automat
Hello
Was ist hier los?
Alles zu?
Da haben sie schon mal Mühe gegeben
Leute, ich muss mal kurz
ich muss mal kurz was machen
Wartet mal
Noclip, wir gucken jetzt mal dahinter
ob er die Hose an hat
Wait a minute
Ach nee, wie war das nochmal?
Scheiße, wie ging Noclip nochmal?
Cheats?
Nee
Alter, der Chat weiß es wieder
Der Chat weiß es wieder
Cheats, genau, Cheats 1
Noclip
Hallo
Da ist ja gar nichts dahinter
Da sind nur die Füße
Scammed
Den gibt es gar nicht
Außer dass da eine Kackalake rumrennt
Den gibt es nicht
Da sind einfach nur die Füße da
Einfach nur die Füße da
Und Sound-Samples
Wunderbar
Dann muss ich jetzt aufpassen, dass ich hier nicht rausklippe
Und jetzt aber
Noclip wieder aus
Perfekt
Und hier SV
Cheats, schauen wir auch aus
Wunderbar, safe
Ich glaube wir haben nichts geprickt oder so
Keine Kackalaken
Wir haben sie echt Mühe gegeben
Ich glaube das ist so ein typischer Mod von einer Person erstellt wieder
Und was mich ja auch schon im originalen Half-Life immer überrascht hat ist
Wie kaputt in Black Mesa alles ist
Also unabhängig von dem, dass alles explodiert und so
Das Zeug ist auch so schon die ganze Zeit immer richtig kaputt
Was geht?
Ah
Nice Head-Grafics
Frisst der da?
Guck mal, leider habe ich kein Meme-Board mehr
Sonst würde ich jetzt den machen
Ich glaube der sitzt dahinter und frisst
Kommt man hier durch?
Ah, nice
Geh man
Pippo-Fat-Wachmann am Start
War hier in der Mitte irgendj-
Was passiert wenn man da runterspringt?
Sack
Muss ich mal kurz überprüfen
Okay, das war klar
Das war klar
Haben wir hier irgendwas?
Gut, das ist alles noch ein Intro
Da kann uns nichts passieren
Corona
Monka Corona
Schon in 2018
Chain Chains?
Ja
Okay
Chain Law, ich habe gerade angefangen
Da haben sie sich schon Mühe gegeben
Ist das das Ding wo man am Anfang in Half-Life 1 durchfährt mit der Bahn?
Nee, ich glaube nicht
Sieht aber so ähnlich
Nee, das ist der Haupteingang
Guckt mal
Das ist der Haupteingang wo man dann später raus
Nee, oder?
Nee, doch nicht
Nee, das ist eine komplett andere Map
Sieht nur so ähnlich aus
Wahrscheinlich hat er die Map re-used vom originalen Half-Life
Nodders
Die haben sie schon
Die haben
Der will jetzt aufs Auto springen
Der hat sich echt Mühe gegeben
Das ist alles von einer Person erstellt
Den Kram hier zu Scriptorn
Ist doch alles kaputt in Black Mesa
Alles kaputt
So ein komischer Getränkeautomat
Huge Cactus
Das Echo hört sich ein bisschen falsch an
Hopp
Man hatte gute Arbeitsbedingungen
Offensichtlich
Nein, ging ja nie was schief
Schön
Jetzt nicht lang
Komm her, die haben es mit den Maps, sie haben sich wirklich Mühe gegeben
Ich hab hier selbst ein bisschen gemapped in Half-Life 1
Natürlich
Also ich konnte das nie so gut
Das ist nicht ohne so Krams zu bauen
In Worldcraft
Worldedit? Worldcraft hieß es glaube ich damals
Was geht?
Moment
Der reagiert drauf, wenn man ins Wasser hüpft
Das ist ja cool
Ob wir da rein können?
Triggered
Hat keiner gesehen
Hallo
Was war das für ein Geräusch vom Dach im Klo hier?
Leute
Ich will ja Twitch nicht triggern, aber
Norders oder
Mal gucken ob da auch nur die Füße dahinter stehen
Monka Toss
Komm wir gucken mal kurz bei den Mädels hinter die Tür
Hallo
Hallo Mädels
Wo bin ich da?
Guck mal da sind nicht nur die Füße
Da sind nicht nur die Füße
Das ist die Trainingskursfrau
Das ist die aus dem
Aus dem Hazard Dings Kurs
Noclip aus
SV Cheats auch null
Männer Klo
Ehrlich gesagt
So wo gehts denn lang?
Da?
Ach ne einfach hier unten
Null
Sieht aus wie 95
Es gibt nicht Sektor C
In Sektor C passiert doch alles
Das heißt wir fahren auf jeden Fall nochmal Bahn
Guck mal der sieht mich
Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht das originale G-Man Modell
das sich gedreht hat ohne die Füße zu bewegen
Nope
Kommt man da hoch?
Zack
Oh
Meine Jump Skills in Half Life
Immer noch hier Top Notch
Ich glaube man soll hier
Hier oben
Ich glaube man soll hier nicht hoch
Boomer müde
Boomer schlafen
Aber wir haben noch Zeit 2 Stunden
Über 2 Stunden
2 Stunden 45
Ich finde es geil gemacht
Die reagieren alle drauf
Guck mal die reagieren alle drauf
Wenn du hier doof rumjumpst
Jebaited
Nein
Nein ich darf nicht mehr raus
Das klingt nicht richtig
Das klingt?
Was ist das?
Mann das klingt schlecht
Lass dich ruhig auslösen
Ich habe ein schlechtes Gefühl über das
Na?
Hast du eine Idee was zu tun?
Wir machen das zusammen
Ich bin ein Sicherheitsgärtner
Sollte niemand tun
Wir machen das zusammen
Das läuft ja nicht auf der Source Engine
Das läuft ja noch auf Gold Source
Das ist ein echter Half-Life 1 Mod
Das können nicht die Source Models sein
Was ich cool finde
Guck mal unten das Symbol
Wie heißt das Ding auf Deutsch?
Dieser Anzug
Der H-E-C-V-Suit
Wir kriegen anscheinend nur kugelsichere Westen
Das sind nicht die ursprünglichen Models aus Half-Life
Das ist das Texture Pack
Es gab ein offizielles Texture Pack
Für Half-Life
Ich vermute mal das ist das
Ihr habt doch gerade den G-Man gesehen
Ich zeige es euch nur mal
G-Man Half-Life 1
Der sah deutlich schlechter aus im Original
Hier
So sah der Original aus
Das war eindeutig das bessere Model
Was wir eben schon gesehen haben
Time 8.57
Okay
So tief bin ich in der Half-Life-Floor nicht drinne
Dass ich weiß wann exakt das in Half-Life passiert ist
Ich hab die Half-Life-Floor eh nicht so komplett kapiert
Oh, ich bin stuck
Fuck Leute
Ich bin stuck
Ich hab mich gestuck im Elevator
Moment
Ja okay
Ich bewege mich auch nicht weiter
Ich bleib ganz brav in der Mitte stehen
Stimmt ich hätte raus Snow Clippen können
Aber nicht dass ich den noch kaputt mache
Ist alles kaputt in Black Mesa
Guckt es euch an
Was geht
Oh, das hätte ich nicht gedacht dass man da stirbt
Wollt einfach nur gucken was passiert
Okay Leute
Das Sound ist kaputt
Das Sound ist kaputt wenn man hier
Wenn man hier neu lädt
Das Sound ist kaputt
Die haben mich hier reingepackt
Dass ich nicht frei rumwufen kann
Dass die Skrits nicht kaputt gehen 100%
Die haben mich hier reingepackt dass ich nicht frei rumwufen kann
Die 2 2 Sound effects
Ernopedia das einer mit dem Mikrofon nachgesprochen
Catherine Flamme Animation
Nein
Ich klippe nicht raus
Das ist kaputt
schreckt
was?
wut's?
get back
ahhhh ahhhh ahhhh ahhhh ahhhh
ahhh yes
oh
ey alter
genau das bringt's wahrscheinlich jetzt
da draufschä..da draufballern
Das war jetzt die Big Brain Idee vom Wachmann. Der hat echt den Five Head Award gewonnen.
Richtig Next Level Brain.
Es spawnet irgendwas unbekanntes, gepanzertes Folie. Bam, erst mal drauf schießen.
Schaske Kona. Na gut, sie spielt bei den Amis. Na, ist das normal. Wenn irgendwas unbekanntes gefährlich ist, ist erst mal drauf schießen.
Sag mal, wäre ich gerade gezogen?
Wäre ich gezogen? Kann das sein? Sollte es mir sagen, ich werde gezogen?
Ja, ich vermute mal, ich werde gerade gezogen über den Boden.
Oh, da liegt eine Shotgun. Habt ihr das gesehen? Brauche ich.
Es gab hier in Opposing Force einen Clip, dann konnte man im Intro eine Waffe aufnehmen.
Und die hat man dann behalten und ist gespawnt mit der Waffe, wo man sie nicht haben sollte. Oh, wow. What the fuck?
Okay, ich gebe zu, das hat mich tatsächlich jetzt ein bisschen erschreckt.
Normalerweise kannst du mich nicht so einfach erschrecken wie sowas, aber das war gut getimed.
Half-Life, alle Teile, auch alle Teile durchspielen, das sind wir ja ewig beschäftigt.
Black Mesa habe ich schon mal uns und stream durchgespielt.
Wo sind die jetzt alle hin?
Alle weg?
Haben mich wiederbelebt und haben sie gedacht, oh nee, gehen wir mal.
Kaputt, okay.
Jetzt würde ich sagen, typische Half-Life Geschichte, erst mal Brecheisen und Pistole suchen.
Oh, das sind Zombies, wobei das keine Zombies sind, ich weiß aber gerade nicht, wie die in Half-Life heißen.
Kann man das aufnehmen?
Ich habe hier mal eine Taschenlampe dabei.
Stopp, ich habe hier mal eine Taschenlampe dabei.
Der ist ja gut.
Das klingt nach Headcrabs.
Da ist er wieder, habt ihr ihn gesehen?
Da war er.
Oh, okay.
Da roppt was um die Ecke.
Oh, äh, das war eben noch nicht da.
Gehen wir mal nach vorne.
Das war eben noch nicht da.
Gehen wir mal safen.
Leute, wenn ihr Half-Life 1 gespielt habt, habt ihr auch den Reflex im Luftschacht immer Crouch gedrückt zu halten,
weil dich das Original Half-Life, hatte ich gerne mal jebaited,
wenn du hier ohne Crouch langgelaufen bist im Original Half-Life, ist er aufgestanden
und du hast deinen Kopf in so einem Ventilator drin gehabt und warst RIP.
Deswegen, ich drücke im Luftschacht immer Crouch.
Kam der Schlingel.
Hast du eigentlich eine 3000er RTX?
Nee, ich habe eine 1080 Ti.
Taschenlampe.
Oh, das ist ja gemein.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Da hat die Pistole gelegen.
Pistole, Pistole und Taschenlampe.
Jebaited, Alter, jebaited.
Ja, ist ja gut.
Das übertreibt es mal nicht.
Moment, es sind...
Das ist aus.
Die Zensur ist wieder an.
Die deutsche Versionszensur ist wieder an.
Kegwaid.
Zack, Moment.
Ich muss gucken, wie man das einschaltet.
Violence.
Ah.
Ah, gibs.
Die haben die Zensur wieder eingeschaltet von der deutschen Version.
Ja, das brauchen wir, genau.
Violence.
Plot 1.
So, damit kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Damit schaltet man das ein.
Aber ich glaube, das konnte man nicht alles so eingeben.
Okay, eins.
Eins.
Wir dürfen nicht neu starten.
Sonst müssen wir das neu machen.
Das kann man bestimmt beim Start hinterlegen.
H-Blatt und?
Und was sonst noch?
Äh.
A-Blatt.
Eins.
Und jetzt irgendwie noch die Kerls.
Ja.
So, jetzt haben wir die deutsche Zensur ausgeschaltet.
Das muss ich, glaube ich, bei den Startoptionen mal reinhauen.
So.
Ich hab das nämlich eben gesehen.
Normalerweise ist es so,
wenn irgendwas splattert,
dann splattert es richtig und es fliegen die Teile rum.
Von den Gegnern.
Das war nicht, deswegen waren wir klar,
die haben deutsche Zensur wieder an.
Bist, bist vor nichts geweilt hier.
Knopf.
Leiter.
Es ist echter Wahnsinn, das zu spielen.
Na, guck mal, das ist ein Spiel von 1998
oder 1997 oder so.
Warum hat das in der aktuellen Steam-Version
überhaupt immer noch
German Zensur drinne?
Warum, warum?
Oh, oh, oh.
Alles klar.
Ich dachte, man kommt da ohne springen hin.
Deathcounter.
Auch sowas.
Huge Jump.
Und jetzt?
Alter, Half-Life 1 Controls.
Please.
Jetzt haben wir's.
Okay.
Hier geht's nicht weiter, also müssen wir
den Kram wahrscheinlich runterpushen.
Half-Life 1 Physics.
So, ist hier irgendwas?
Und jetzt?
Ach so, hier durchklettern, würde ich sagen.
Geht das?
Zack.
Ah, Mist, ich wollte...
Nee, jetzt komm ich nicht mehr rein.
Ich wollte gucken, ob man da oben rein kann.
Ja, klar.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, so ausweglos
kann es ja nie sein, dass ich hier freiwillig
reinhüpfe wird.
Ist klar.
Natürlich.
Ach, guck mal, die haben den Pepo
fett wach, man.
Okay.
Hab ich die...
Die Brechstange
irgendwo übersehen?
Oder soll ich echt noch keine
Waffe haben? Ich glaube, ich soll noch keine
Waffe haben.
Alter, jetzt übertreiben
sie es aber.
Jetzt übertreiben sie es aber.
Oh, da ist kein Knopf dran.
Leute, jetzt mal no shit.
Das schockt
mich mehr als jedes Slender-Game.
Slender-Game habe ich drüber gelacht,
habe ich gesagt, woop, vorbei.
Wer kann sich über sowas erschrecken?
Hier erschreckst du dich wirklich ab und zu.
Vor allem auch, wie sie das Licht hier
jetzt noch gemacht haben.
Ohne Headcrab
Stelle es hinter mir.
Nichts wie weg.
Da haben sie sich echt hier
ins Zeug gelegt.
Oh.
Ich habe keine Brechstange.
Was mache ich jetzt?
Ich brauche eine Brechstange.
Wo ist eine Brechstange?
Gib, gib Brechstange.
Moment, hier
sind wir eben schon lange, oder?
Ja.
Oh.
Haha.
Ich dachte, es ist nicht gescriptet.
Okay, es ist gescriptet. Oh fuck, falsche Richtung.
Gehst du fort?
Ich dachte, es ist nicht gescriptet.
Na ja gut, kann ja mal passieren.
Alter, gehst du fort?
Ich habe keine Brechstange.
Wo ist meine Brechstange? Ich brauche meine Brechstange.
Moin, Michael.
50 Billion, lau wieder am Start.
Wo ist meine Brechstange?
Ich muss bashen, Alter.
Aha, aha, Kugelsichere Weste.
Sehr gut.
Erstmal looten.
Immer looten.
Und erstmal
hier. Ah, yes.
Eine Runde Cola
saufen.
Wait a minute. Ah.
Okay, vielleicht
ist es doch übertrieben, damit die Leben aufzufüllen.
In dem Game
kriegst du keine Waffen. Nee, oder?
Nee, da
muss ich Waffen kriegen, sonst hätten die nicht am Anfang
die Shotgun gespawnt.
Hold on a minute.
Brechstange.
Poggers.
Was jetzt?
Erstmal looten.
Komm mal, ich habe Munition gekriegt.
Deswegen.
Allein schon deswegen kriege ich was.
Da spawnen fast hinter mir.
Fuck.
Massive Headcrab.
Stells.
Da fuck.
Wo ist sie?
Headcrab, komm her.
Auf.
Wow.
Schreckt.
Get fucked up in the ass over here.
Auf.
Huge Zombie AI.
Aufspringen.
Headcrab, springen.
Mal gucken, jetzt kann ich mal überprüfen,
ob, ob, ob es an ist.
Ja.
Violent Stings.
Blue Defected.
Deutsche Zensur ist aus, sonst könnte man die, sonst
könnte man die Headcrabs nicht zersplendern.
Alter, wie sie angetäuscht hat.
Erst angetäuscht, dass sie nicht funktioniert.
Als wäre sie bugged und dann doch auf einmal.
In the ass, in the ass.
Eine Güte, ey.
Die sind ja recht aggressive.
Die springen verzögert.
Das ist übelst fies.
Da kannste dich überhaupt nicht drauf einstellen.
So, erstmal, erstmal
Headcrab zersplendern.
Oh.
Bam.
So muss das sein.
So, kann man den Typ jetzt zersplendern?
Nope.
Äh, aufladen.
Erstmal
Pippo fährt Cola aus dem Automat.
Ja, erstmal 100% Leben holen.
Oder auch.
Nicht.
Ah, yes.
Uwe.
Alter, ich war gerade
klitscht.
Ich war gerade klitscht in dem Automat,
weil diese Dinger gespawnt sind.
Lull.
Aha.
Okay, die können nichts.
Die sind dumm.
Splendern.
Bam.
Jawoll.
Okay, wenn nicht muss wieder
irgendwelche Räder drehen.
Jawoll.
Was sonst?
Und es spawnt bestimmt wieder was
hinter mir.
Okay, was auch immer.
Daneben spawnt was.
Moin Jungs, was geht?
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max.
Leute, wusste ihr, dass ich ganz lange dachte,
ich muss immer einmal klicken?
Ich hab früher Half-Life 1, hab ich so
Nahkampfattacken gemacht. Passt mal auch so.
Bis ich dann irgendwann
gecheckt habe, ah, man kann auch die
Maustaste einfach halten.
Ich mag die Half-Life 1
Splattergeräusche.
Habt ihr gehört?
Das Minikit sagt exzellent.
Da fuck, dieses Kackding.
Ich hab gedacht, ich bin ausgewischen.
Die Dinger haben nur zwei Attacken.
Einmal diese Doppel Cleave und dann
so von unten können nichts.
Aber ich lasse mich trotzdem
hitten.
Und man konnte
die eigentlich übelst gut outstraven,
normalerweise.
Passt mal auf, die Dinger sind dumm.
Die Dinger sind richtig dumm.
Okay.
Die checken es nicht.
Wait a minute.
Nee, hier waren wir schon.
Äh.
Wie viele von dem Zeug
gibt es hier eigentlich?
Macht das Ding platt, bevor ich Kisten lute.
Richtige Ottos halt, genau.
Und splattern, please.
Oh, kein Bock.
Money sammeln, das heißt,
ich krieg bald noch ne Pistole.
Oh.
Wird auch Zeit.
Genug Brechstangen Action.
Äh.
Ah, die wollen wir jetzt sagen,
die mussten das Level nachladen.
Angeblich bin ich hier durchgekommen, verstehe.
Bam.
Oder auch nicht.
No storage.
Keep clear.
Machen wir.
Und jetzt?
Moment.
Das hat mir nur...
Ach nee, ich bin auf Medikit gefallen.
Lässt sich nicht alles splattern.
Und jetzt?
Ah.
Oh.
Ich glaube, ich muss mich beeilen.
Oh, das wird knapp, das wird knapp, das wird knapp, das wird knapp.
Oh.
Kann noch im Kopf durch.
Ich hab erst...
Das ist noch ziemlich am Anfang, du hast nicht viel verpasst.
So.
Geschreckt.
Jetzt können wir wirklich mal abschließen und testen,
ob deutsche Zensur ausgeschaltet ist.
Wenn der jetzt zerplatzt gleich,
dann wissen wir, es ist alles...
Okay, deutsche Zensur ist aus.
Das gab's in der deutschen Version nicht.
Dass die Dinger in irgendwelchen...
Ja, nein, das gab's in der deutschen Version definitiv nicht.
Und jetzt?
Was ist hier?
Sex.
Unterschubsen?
Warte mal, kann ich da...
Ah.
Boah.
In your face.
Kann ich hier durch?
Ah, hier ist ein Holzbrett.
Aufladen.
Ach Mist, ich hab ja kein...
Die Dinger sind übelst als Chebat hier.
Die wirst du nie verwenden können.
Okay.
Äh...
Wie genau
komm ich hier jetzt?
Oh, gut, passt.
Was ist das?
Nee, das geht nicht kaputt.
Hä?
Keine Ahnung, was die von mir wollen.
Wahrscheinlich gar nichts.
Wollte ich da jetzt rein?
Wahrscheinlich.
Yolo-Jump. Perfekt.
Easy.
So, was will das Game jetzt von mir?
Teicht mal her.
Ähm...
Half-Life Logik, Half-Life Logik.
Komm mal, da oben ist ne Kiste.
Da oben ist ne Kiste und da unten ist ne Kiste.
Okay, die Kiste muss hier auf jeden Fall durch.
Wie? Wie jetzt?
Ich denk, das ist Holz.
Ah.
Okay, das ist Big Brain Half-Life Logik.
Das geht nur, wenn man an der richtigen Stelle steht.
Bim, bim, bim, bim, bim.
So, jetzt muss man das bestimmt hier rumpushen.
Und jetzt?
Jetzt crabb ich das mal.
Oh!
Alter!
Wenn man diese Kisten crabbt, beschleunigt das übelst.
Okay, jetzt weiß ich, was ich machen muss.
Ich muss die Kisten da reinschmeißen.
Die bestimmt auch noch.
Das ist ein typisches Half-Life Rätsel.
Das hat der Mod-Typ echt gut gemacht.
Oh, das hat...
Das war so ein typisches Half-Life Rätsel.
Sowas gab es ihm auch jedenfalls auch so komische Dinge, wo du...
Wo du eigentlich nicht genau wusstest, was du machen musst.
So.
Der jetzt auch noch da.
Alter, wie schnell der wird, wenn der die Kiste crabbt.
So, kann ich jetzt durch?
Kann ich hier durch?
Ich meine, der Typ ist auch durchgekommen.
Wir gehen einfach hier durch.
Nein, ich kann nicht durch.
Okay.
Ähm...
Da war noch eine Kiste hinten, ne?
Da war noch eine Kiste hinten.
Die muss ich wahrscheinlich holen.
Muss wahrscheinlich die Kiste holen.
Hallo, Half-Life, please.
Darf ich hier hoch?
Da muss ich die Kiste holen.
Und dann muss ich die da noch reinschmeißen.
Weil die haben nicht umsonst da oben so drei Lichter hingemacht.
So.
Aha.
Ah, yes.
Oh, Headcrabs.
Das wollte ich schon immer mal probieren.
Nein, das nicht.
Kann man eine Headcrab?
Kann man eine Headcrab hier reinlocken?
Das muss ich ausprobieren.
Nice.
Das geht, das wusste ich noch gar nicht.
Ich hab noch nie eine Headcrab in so ein Ding gelockt.
Gleich platzt die Headcrab.
So, auf gleich.
Jawoll.
Physix?
Physix, please.
Okay.
Wie genau bin ich an den Knopf gekommen?
Diese Kisten haben so geile Physik in Half Life 1.
Okay.
Jetzt muss ich hier...
Alter, wie schnell.
Guck mal, wie...
Nein.
Da, andere Richtung.
Guck mal, wie krass man beschleunigt.
Kiste, please.
Come on.
Geh hier durch.
Bam.
Und jetzt kann ich bestimmt hier unten durch.
Genau, jetzt geht es kaputt.
Und jetzt kann ich durch.
Nice.
Wieder typische Half Life Logik.
Okay.
Passt mal auf, Trick 17.
Was?
Das ist too bad.
Da war überhaupt nichts.
Da konnte ich überhaupt nicht sterben.
Guck mal, das geht überhaupt nicht.
Da ist nichts, was mich killen kann.
Ich muss mal kurz Luft holen.
Guck mal.
Da muss ich gar nicht lang.
Ich hätte einfach warten müssen, bis das Wasser steigt.
Ach so.
Ja, da muss man erst drauf kommen.
Jetzt gehe ich einfach zurück und klette auf der anderen Seite hoch.
Ja, guck da.
Plopp.
Da sind wir.
Half Life POC, ja, Half Life Mod POC.
Wo kommst denn du her?
Wo...
Cheater.
Richtige Cheater.
Hier war vorhin nichts.
Und jetzt ist er da von hinten.
Da ist noch einer.
Au.
Heck, Alter.
Und splattern, please.
Eine Runde splattern.
Ich muss alles zersplattern.
Die platzen nicht.
Na gut, dann nicht.
Wenn die nicht platzen.
Noch einer.
Vielleicht platzt du ja.
Was?
Okay Leute, ich bin fair, ich lade nicht neu.
Normalerweise würde ich jetzt neu laden, wenn ich es verkacke.
Okay, die kann man nicht zersplattern.
Was haben wir da?
Kann man auch nicht zersplattern?
Gut, das ist ein Skelett.
Wie soll man Skelett zersplattern?
So, einmal Gabelstapler.
Ich brauche eine Pistole.
Es gibt bestimmt bald eine Pistole.
Guck mal, ich habe die ganze Zeit schon
Money gesammelt.
Und ich habe noch keine Pistole.
Das kommt bestimmt gleich.
Hopp.
Okay, Half-Life Prediction.
Half-Life Prediction, Leute.
Ich laufe jetzt da durch.
Und entweder
bricht das hier ein.
Es stürzt fast
durch die Decke.
Oder es spawnt irgendwas vor mir
oder hinter mir.
Du kannst in Half-Life nicht durch so einen
Korridor laufen, ohne dass eines dieser
Sachen passiert. Schauen wir mal.
Okay.
Es spawnet nicht bei mir.
Es spawnet bei den anderen was.
Ich habe falsch gelegen.
Oder der Fisch
springt dagegen.
Aber nah dran.
Der hat ihn gekillt.
Ich glaube, das sollte so nicht sein, dass der den killt.
Ich glaube,
die sollten alle geschreckt werden
von dem Squid.
Wie heißen die Dinger?
Diese Dinger da.
Jetzt muss ich die Headcrab baiten.
Pass auf.
Headcrab bait.
Ach du Scheiße.
Okay.
Ich laufe jetzt einfach durch.
Ist hier irgendwie was?
Nope.
Ach guck mal.
Die Headcrabs wurden gestälzt von dem Ding.
Guck, das Ding frisst gerade die Headcrab.
Hier gibt es aber nichts mehr.
Alter.
Jetzt lade ich aber neu.
Auch so ein Explosionsstälzer.
Haut ab.
Okay, jetzt kriege ich bald die Pistole.
Wisst ihr, woher ich das weiß?
Weil die Dinger kannst du nicht gescheit mit der Prechtange platt machen.
Geht nicht.
Die, die, äh,
ich, diese
Dog-Dinger.
Die kannst du nicht
gescheit killen mit der Prechtange.
Hallo?
Ist hier auch eine Sache, die ich mich
persönlich immer bei Half-Life gefragt habe.
Also auch schon im Original.
Wer baut so was?
Ich mein.
Was ist das für ein Gang, Alter?
Ein Gang und dann hat man
noch zusätzlich so Dinger und Holzteile
davor gebaut.
Ja gut.
Schreck.
Okay.
Moment, der wirft jetzt,
der wirft jetzt, der wirft jetzt
mit dem Fass auf mich.
Oder was anderes kann doch
gar nicht passieren.
Hot, Hot Steam?
Wo ist der Pool?
Hot Steam Pool Stream?
Der wirft das Ding auf mich,
wenn ich da jetzt drüber gehe.
Warum soll ich da drüber gehen?
Ich mein, ich sehe,
dass der Typ auf mich aimt.
Ich wäre so dumm, da drüber zu springen.
Aber ich muss drüber springen,
weil es sonst wahrscheinlich nicht weitergeht.
Außer ich kann hier lang.
Nein. Vielleicht kann ich den Schalter
klitschen dadurch.
Nee.
Kann man das hier schieben?
Okay.
Dann geh ich mal da rüber und lass mich von dem Fass hitten.
Ah Mist, ich dachte ich da nichts vorher.
Aber das ist Geskript.
Ja ist doch gut.
Jetzt wollen sie mich schocken wieder hier.
Oh!
MonkaS!
Damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet.
Ich dachte, ganz ehrlich,
ich dachte,
jetzt kommt hier ein Wachmann raus und killt das Ding.
Oder wisst ihr was richtig
geil gewesen wäre?
Wenn da jetzt Gordon Freeman rausgekommen wäre
und hätte das Ding weggeschottgut
und wäre wieder verschwunden.
Allerdings können sie das
ja nicht machen, weil wir haben das
Original Half Life gespielt und da ist so was nicht
vorgekommen.
Da ist meine
Man brecheisen.
Meine Crowbar. Gib her!
Das Ding ist immer noch da,
was hier gerade rumgehüpft ist.
Gut, so rum kommen wir schon mal nicht.
Du Sau!
Guckt euch an!
Der Gamer, Mann!
Okay, ich muss hier lang.
Hier oder hier?
Okay, hier geht es nicht weiter.
Hier geht es nicht weiter.
Ich weiß nicht, normalerweise würde ich jetzt hier...
Normalerweise würde ich jetzt hier nicht lang gehen.
Also wenn ich das wäre, würde ich dann...
Ehrlich gesagt hätte ich einfach gecampt
am Spawnpunkt, so IRL.
Äh, und welche Tür ist jetzt genau
aufgegangen?
Welche Tür ist jetzt
Wonka S. Luftschachtstellz.
Ah, hier drüben die,
hä?
Welche Tür ist jetzt auf?
Ah, hier ist jetzt auf!
Da war vorher nicht offen.
Okay.
Ah, da fuck!
Das ist ja echt nichts für schwache Nerven hier!
Wonka S.
Wonka W.
Precheisen. Perfekt.
Meine Güte!
Die ziehen aber jetzt echt alle Gegister hier, oder?
Splattern, jawoll!
Äh.
So.
Mach auf!
Ja, mach auf!
Mann, hab keinen Bock.
Oh!
Hehe!
Grip.
So, äh, hab ich jetzt irgendwas übersehen?
Oder war ich hier wieder am Ausgang?
Nee, ne?
Ich hab alles, passt.
Wunderbar, ich kann jetzt hier abhauen.
Die haben sich aber wirklich verdammt viel Mühe gegeben,
das muss man mal sagen.
Oder? Gibt's hier noch was?
So dass das von einer Person wieder gemacht haben,
die sich sehr viel Mühe gegeben haben.
Ah! Pistole! Pistole!
Es gibt Pistole! Ich hör Pistolen-Schüsse!
Pistole!
Endlich!
Pock!
Nö, nö.
Ich habe die Vermutung, das ist ein Mod,
wo man Munition sparen muss.
Gibt's hier irgendwas?
Irgendwie Hellz?
Hellz-Pack oder sowas?
Hellz-Pack?
Oder war... Chat, habt ihr's mitbekommen?
War da ein Hellz-Pack drin und ich hab's nicht mitgekriegt,
da ich's aufgenommen hab, oder?
Oder bin ich zu
Low IQ dafür?
Was, was genau
lädt er nach?
Ok, jetzt haben wir eine Pistole. Exzellent.
Das Problem ist, dass es zu viele Gegner sind
für eine Pistole.
Oh, die können wir hier reinloggen. Pass mal auf hier.
Massive, Massive. Komm her, lasst euch fressen.
Erster, erster,
nächster, nächster, komm her,
da oben ist der G-Mann, was macht der da?
Jawoll, next, next,
next, next, hier.
Auf, auf, kommt her, kommt her.
Kommt her.
Munition sparen, zack.
Next.
Lol, she baited.
Huge reactions.
Mist, jetzt hab ich das Ding gekillt.
Das brauch ich doch noch.
Hier ist noch einer.
Kommst du her?
Zwei Stück, zwei Stück, einen hau ich da
mit der Brechstange um.
Jawoll.
Und jetzt einer, du hier noch, komm.
Hier bin ich, komm her.
Hier bin ich. Wo ist denn der andere hin?
Ah, okay.
Weggesplattered, jawoll.
So, jetzt können wir hier mal in Ruhe gucken.
Also, hier kommen wir her, hier geht's nicht lang.
Da gibt's ein Auto,
da gibt's Zeug.
Da ist was Grünes drin gewesen.
Boin, Fleisch,
Flöten, Träger.
Aha.
Oh, guck mal.
Shotgun.
Poggers.
Jetzt werden sie geschreckt.
Jetzt haben sie keine Chance mehr.
Jetzt werden sie gebashed, Alter.
Und noch mehr Muni.
Da kann ja gar nichts mehr schiefgehen jetzt.
Guck mal hier, 56 Schuss.
6 Schuss Shotgun.
Keine Chance mehr.
Keine Chance mehr. Oh, die brauch ich jetzt auch.
Okay, nur noch 3 Schuss Shotgun.
2 Schuss Shotgun.
Und da hinten, guck mal, da hinten stellt's noch.
Da hinten stellt's noch. Wo ist es hin?
Wie, da kann ich nicht durchschießen.
Skamast.
Jetzt reichen, glaube ich, 3 Headshots
bei den Dingern.
Hallo. 1, 2, 3,
4.
Blind.
Leicht, leicht IQ-Probleme
der Mob.
3 Headmops.
Meine Güte, was geht denn hier überall ab?
Richtige 3 Kopfmops.
Das ist eins hier in der Mitte.
Ein Klo.
Der ist zu.
Ah, Hälst.
Ey, weißt du was?
Bam.
Halsmaul, Alter.
Piss dich, Alde.
Weg.
Was wie? Fisch-KI?
Noclip ins Klo.
Nee, da ist nichts dahinter.
Guck mal, da, da geht's hoch.
Was ist denn da?
Da ist nichts. Aber da drüben ist was.
Kann man den, kann man den.
50 Euro für einen Raspberry Pi
mit Netzteil und Gehäuse.
Das ist okay.
Fuck.
Alter, seid ihr gemein.
Das macht man doch nicht.
Aber es gibt, aber es gibt wenigstens
ein bisschen Rüstung.
Die spawnen die Headcrab einfach direkt.
Ich hab da gar keine Chance auszuweichen.
So, jetzt locken wir die Dinge erstmal
wieder rein. Hallo, hier bin ich.
Komm her.
Wie?
Ihr sollt da nicht dran vorbeilaufen.
Ihr sollt da gefälligst
reinlaufen.
Komm her.
Kommt her. Wie?
Was ist das? Warum
lauft ihr da nicht rein?
Ja, welcher Raspberry Pi ist die Frage. Aber ich vermute mal,
dass es ein 2 oder 4G
ist.
Ansonsten wäre es natürlich deutlich zu billig.
Eher ein 2G. Aber das ist kein Problem.
Vielleicht auch.
So.
Was haben wir da?
Überreste.
Sag mal, gibt es wirklich
Geräusche, wenn man da drüber läuft? Habt ihr das gerade gehört?
Das ist mir ja noch nie so aufgefallen,
dass es Matschgeräusche gibt,
wenn man vielleicht über Leichenteile läuft.
Das war mir so
nicht bewusst.
So, ich glaube, hier ist
sonst nichts mehr.
Den kann ich immer noch nicht benutzen.
Ja, 2G reicht, aber vollkommen
aus Rebell.
Vollkommen ausreichend.
Es sei denn, du willst da, du weißt genau,
was du machen willst, dass du mehr brauchst. Aber ansonsten
ist es vollkommen ok.
2G.
Grenade.
Viele Headcrabs.
Weiß jemand, wie Headcrabs auf Deutsch
heißen?
Wie heißt dieser Mob offiziell auf
Deutsch?
Die heißen doch nicht wirklich
Kopfkrabben.
Nein, oder?
Das ist die offizielle, das ist
sag mal, das ist das offensichtlichste,
was mir auch eingefallen wäre. Aber die werden ja nicht so blöd
sein, die Kopfkrabbe genannt haben, oder?
Nein, das glaube ich.
Ernsthaft? Ok, das glaube ich euch nicht.
Head.
Crab.
German.
Kopfkrabbe.
Das heißt, die haben das Ding
nicht wirklich Kopfkrabbe genannt, oder?
Sehr gut.
Warum nicht?
Dann, liebe Headcrab.
Erstmal alle Headcrabs entsorgen.
Haben wir da?
Windows 95.
Unzerstörbares
Dieser Stream ist jetzt Deutsch.
Kopfkrabbe.
Ah, da gehts raus.
Perfekt.
Weiter gehts.
Ok, wir müssen bestimmt wieder
Oh, da ist ein großes Viech.
Wir müssen bestimmt wieder die Rädchen drehen, oder so.
Na, vielleicht was?
Looten.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ah, ah.
Oh, oh.
Jetzt ist ja gut hier.
Was soll das hier?
Da spawnen die einfach um mich drum herum.
Ok, zum Glück sind die Mops so dumm.
Zum Glück sind die Mops so dumm, Alter.
Zum Glück seid ihr so hängen geblieben.
So, alles dead.
Grip.
Was haben wir hier? Kommen wir da hoch? Nein.
Kann man den splattern?
Der hat da, ich sehs genau.
Der hat eine MP5.
Ich will da eine MP5 haben.
Kämpfst du mir deine MP5?
Nein.
Nicht.
Du hast das nicht gedacht.
Hallo.
Oh.
Anzeige jetzt raus.
Nichts wie weg.
Und zu.
Ah, das ist ja hinter mir.
Shit.
Ok, wir strafen jetzt.
Wir outstrafen den jetzt einfach.
Jawoll.
Jetzt wollen sie es aber echt wissen hier.
Das wird ja richtig anstrengend langsam.
Was haben wir hier?
Totes Zeug.
Gibt es noch irgendwo Shotgun Schüsse?
Ich bräuchte noch ein paar Shotgun Schüsse, das wäre ganz praktisch.
Ich hab nämlich auch nicht mal viel Money für die Pistole.
Sind das mutierte Meerschweinchen?
Nein, das sind Aliens.
Das ist doch krasse Half-Life Lore.
Das sind Aliens.
Was haben wir hier?
Die Decke bricht ein.
Das ist nicht mehr als im Battlefield.
Ok, ich bin weg.
Ich bin mal weg.
Ich versuche schneller zu laufen, aber ich kann nicht schneller laufen.
Pippo Run.
Aber richtig.
Woop Leaf, Leute. Woop Leaf.
Ah, krieg dich ein.
Da ist was zum drücken, oder?
Oder nicht?
Da ist was zum drücken.
Weg, weg, weg, weg, weg, weg, weg.
Weg.
Schreck.
Ok.
Kann ich die Tür einfach aufgehen?
Einfach Tür aufgehen, mich rauslassen?
Ah, ok, wir haben es geschafft. Sonst hätte es nicht neu geladen.
Ach, guck mal, da kann man durchgucken.
Muss gucken, ob der ordentlich gemapt hat, der Typ.
Der hat...
...ein bisschen mehr Geld als ich.
Aber das ist nicht so schlimm.
Das ist nicht so schlimm.
Der hat...
...ja...
...hat ordentlich gemapt.
Da ist was oben drüber.
So.
Was das gekostet haben muss, so Kram unterirdisch zu bauen.
Black Mesa Leute haben mir keine Kosten und Müllen gescheut.
Aber das war ja schon im Original so.
Dass du dich gefragt hast, warum alles unterirdisch.
Ich vermute mal, ich muss Fahrstuhl fahren.
Ich muss Fahrstuhl fahren.
Oh.
Da ist ein Shotgun, Leute.
Passt mal auf, wir machen jetzt ein Massive Trick 17.
Shotgun.
Shoot.
Shit.
Ha, erwischt.
Okay, das hat jetzt überhaupt nichts gebracht.
Wir haben jetzt weniger Munition wie vorher.
Ich habe komplett Shotgun aufgehoben.
Ich habe alle Shotgun Ammo verbraucht.
Nur noch mehr Pistolen Ammo.
Exzellent.
Five Head Aktion hat sich voll gelohnt.
Outstanding Move.
Guck mal, da winkt einer.
Guck mal, Barney winkt uns.
Einer von 50 Milliarden Barney-Klonen zumindest.
Wo geht's lang?
Unterirdisch gleich geheim.
Ja, das wird's sein.
Sieht ja auch so aus, als müsste das hier unbedingt geheim sein.
Was ist das hier?
Ich hab keine Muni für drei Gegner.
Sind wir da nicht am Anfang runtergekommen?
Stimmt.
Wartet mal, ist das hier der...
Nee, oder?
Granate, stimmt.
Ich hab ne Granate.
Das probieren wir jetzt.
Wartet mal kurz.
Ich kenn null Granatenphysik
von Half-Life 1.
Post-Champ.
Die denken sie jetzt auch, war da was?
Okay, die...
Das interessiert sie nicht.
Also Granatenphysik ist so schonmal nix.
So vielleicht?
Nicht wirklich?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Meine Güte, Granatenphysik, please.
Jetzt aber, jetzt aber.
Die sterben nicht von der Nate.
Und es interessiert die auch überhaupt nicht.
Sind die wenigstens weak, dass ich die mit ein paar
Schuss killen kann?
Nö.
Das ist denen vollkommen egal.
Warte mal, warte mal, ich gucke, ist hier irgendwas wichtiges, ist hier irgendwas, nein, so, ich lade neu und jetzt gucken wir, wo, wo
Was
Ich habe da gespeichert, habe ich da, habe ich da gespeichert
Hab ich Gewurstfinger gespeichert, Leute
Alter, wo schießt denn du hin
Ich habe Wurstfinger gespeichert, fuck, jetzt, so, ich hätte jetzt nämlich versucht, ob man da durch kann, indem man hier runterspringt oder so dran vorbeischleichen oder so
Okay, das war ziemlich
Das war eine, äh, Two-Head-Aktion
Was da? Aha, ein Pistolstelz
Das haben die aber wirklich gut gemacht, ich muss mal den Mod-Ersteller loben
Die haben wirklich dafür gesorgt, dass man genau die richtige Anzahl von Munition hat
Und immer das Gefühl hat, die Munition ist knapp
Das ist eigentlich genau richtig für so ein Game
Ja, okay, und Tschüss
Und Tschüss
Okay
Warte, ich wollte gucken, ob da eine Munition drin ist, warte mal, ich muss da, oh, nein, ich gucke nicht, ob da Munition drin ist
Shotgun
Pongers
Evaded
Ich hab's nicht auf zwei Tasten nebeneinander
Guck mal, ich hab Quicksafe da und Laden da, also komplett unterschiedlicher Knopf
Ich hab's auf F5 speichern, hab ich F5 speichern und sieben, oh
Alter, wie fies, das, komm, das ist doch kacke
Direkt vorm Fahrstuhl, das ist unfair sowas, das macht man nicht
Auf der anderen Seite, das passt insofern in die Half-Life Lore sogar rein, weil diese Dinger sind Massive Brained
Das sind die, die dann quasi Gordon auch retten im zweiten Teil
Warum, verstehe ich bis heute nicht, Half-Life Lore hat sich mir bis nie so ganz erschlossen
Warum die den retten, der Typ killt fünf Spiljarden von ihnen, aber im zweiten Teil retten sie ihn dann, okay
Was, was, was ist das denn Gachi Bass mit dem Wachmann oder wie
Was so, soll das, sieht das nur so aus oder soll das gerade wirklich so sein
Das ist Hyper Gachi gerade, Alien Hyper Gachi
Ah nee, das soll nicht so sein, das war einfach nur ein Skript, was ich erst triggern musste, okay
Ich hab schon gedacht, die wollen mir ernsthaft, da ist er ja wieder
Na, Geh mal Mann, guck mal, er telefoniert
Den G-Man haben sie ja bis heute nicht richtig erklärt, aber Half-Life lebt ja irgendwo mit davon, dass es so ein bisschen vage ist alles
Soll ich jetzt hier durchspringen
Geh sofort
Warum ist der jetzt weg
Wie soll denn das, wie, wie wollt ihr das erklären, wo ist denn der hin jetzt
Kann man die eigentlich auch zersplattern
Im originalen Half-Life haben sie sich immer noch Mühe gegeben, dass es immer so eine Tür oder so gab, wo der hin konnte
Okay
Pass auf, jetzt ist bestimmt hier irgendwie wieder eine Headcrab dahinter
Predicted
Oh, noch mehr Headcrabs dahinter
Auf, spring
Next
Gebated habe ich euch, gebated, Massive gebated
So, was gibt es jetzt hier
Gibt es Shotgun Ammo vielleicht
Nein, es gibt einen Popter Baumeister Helm, excellent 50% kugelsichere Rüstung
Der G-Man ist sicherlich kein Mensch, nee ist er nicht, aber man hat absolut, oder vielleicht, oder vielleicht nicht, also wahrscheinlich nicht, aber so wirklich erklärt haben sie das ja nie
Und wer hat die Arbeitgeber des, oh shit, oh shit
Oh shit
Das kann jetzt nicht euer Ernst gewesen sein, das ist ja richtig gemein
Was ist wenn ich jetzt weniger Leben gehabt hätte, dann wäre ich instant verreckt
Okay, wo geht es lang
Wo, wo geht es lang
Geht wieder alles kaputt in Black Mesa
Hallo, da ist mein Fahrstuhl in Ruhe, ja, oh, oder nicht, kann ich hier raus
Ich fasse besser nichts mehr an, ja in Black Mesa geht alles kaputt
Okay, Zack
Mal schnell nachladen und jetzt um die Ecke pieken
So, und den mache ich auf jeden Fall mit dem Brech-Eisblatt, ich habe nämlich zu wenig Money
Bäm, gebashed, so, nachladen, das Viech da hinten kann mir hier überhaupt nichts machen
Erstmal schauen ob es hier ein bisschen Leben oder sonst wie gibt, weil Leben ist wirklich knapp
Man muss nämlich mal ehrlich sagen, im normalen Half-Life hast du immer Volles
Was ist denn mit euch da hinten los
Na, bin ich raus
MonkaS-Game, richtiges MonkaS-Game
Half-Life 1 Mod
So, das Viech kann mir ja gar nichts
Leider kann man die nicht auskotzen lassen, die haben unendlich viel Spucke
Ja klar
Oh, jetzt ist hier offen, das ist schlecht
Vielleicht kann ich euch, oh, oh, das ist blöd wo ich hier hingehe
Ja, auf Mehl-Attacke machen, Nahkampf-Attacke machen, was ist das für eine Range, Alter
Killt er einfach sein Kollege
So, ich habe ein bisschen wenig Money
Was geht hier eigentlich gerade
Komm mal, da ist ein Lüftungsschacht, da muss ich bestimmt hin, hier geht es nämlich nicht mehr weiter
Da ist ein Lüftungsschacht
Half-Life, Lüftungsschacht, gleich hier muss ich ran
Jawoll, nein, nein, Headcrab
Ich habe nicht mehr viel Leben
Nicht mehr viel Leben und nicht mehr viel Munition
Shotgun nachladen, passt
Das gibt irgendwelche komischen Half-Life Jump'n'Run Rätsel mit Headcrabs in jedem, garantiert, Prediction
Headcrab in jedem Schacht
Ich höre schon welche, rechts, ich höre schon welche
Siehste, nee, nee, nee, so einfach lasse ich mich nicht mehr baiten
Kopfkrabbe, stimmt, dieser Stream ist jetzt deutsch, Kopfkrabbe
Meint ihr, ich bin RIP, wenn ich da runterhüpf?
Ja
Kopfkrabbe
So, Achtung, nächster Lüftschacht, nächste Headcrab
Oder auch nicht
Jetzt habe ich Munition verschwendet, ich kann, noob
Alter, fett Finger
Moment, und warum genau bin ich jetzt hier nochmal lang gekrabbelt?
Hier ist doch überhaupt nichts
Gab es hier noch irgendwas sonst?
Nee
Die Grafik ist für Half-Life 1 Verhältnisse saumäßig gut
Dazu kommt, die haben das auch wohl ordentlich gemoddet hier, ne?
Pass mal auf, jetzt probieren wir mal was, jetzt probieren wir mal was
Huge, huge strafing
Das checkt er nicht, oh fuck
Fuck
Doch doch, das ist die Original-Grafik von Half-Life 1, aber halt mit, mit ein paar Custom, oh fuck
Ok, das hat sich nicht gelohnt, mit Custom-Texturen, mit bisschen verbesserten Models
Oder, sag mal, ist hier was drin?
Monka, ok, ich will, ich muss das Ding killen, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss, oh kann ich das hier rein?
Kann ich das hier, wie, wie, warum kommst du an den Dingern vorbei? Was soll das, ich habe es genau gesehen
Du hast beschissen, du bist hier durchgerannt und
Ok, ok, wir haben es abgehängt, wir haben die KI geklitscht
Spielst du CS? Schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr
Ach guck mal, hier geht es runter, hier geht es ja runter
Aha, exzellent, aber sonst geht es nicht weiter
So, wo muss ich denn, jetzt geh doch mal weg
Ah, das passt von der Größe her nicht, das ist irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, also
Das hat nicht so ganz reingepasst
So, wo muss ich lang, ich habe, da ist noch eine Lüftungsschacht, ich habe ernsthaft, absolut
Das hört sich nicht gut an
Pass auf, hier ist bestimmt wieder eine Headcrab drinne
Ah, vielleicht geht es auch hier weiter
Kann man abkürzen, mein Leute, ich probiere mal was aus
Wahrscheinlich bin ich jetzt RIP, wahrscheinlich bin ich jetzt RIP
Ne, ich habe es versucht nach vorne, ich habe es versucht nach vorne zu drücken, ging nicht
Da muss ich das Ding killen, eins, zwei, drei, vier
Ich brauche Leben
Ich muss sagen, die Farbgebung ist mir ein bisschen zu viel Grau, Rot und Grün
Oh, wo kommt denn das Ding her, warum ist das Ding jetzt auf einmal da, das war eben noch nicht da
Ich vermute mal, ich muss das irgendwie killen jetzt mit irgendeinem Trigger hier
Ok, es hat mich noch nicht gesehen, es hat mich nicht gesehen, Stellzmodus, Stellzmodus
Stellzmodus, Stellzmodus
By the way, man konnte in Half-Life schleichen, das wissen die wenigsten
Und die Monster hatten damals schon geskriptet, was die hören und geskriptet, was die riechen
Tatsächlich, das haben die 1998 schon gemacht
Ok, ähm
Was genau will das Spiel von mir
Da ist ein Ofen, da ist, ne da brennt was, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich das dahin
Aber guck mal, es lässt sich übelst stellzen, guck mal
Guck mal, das checkt es nicht
Da oben kommen wir her
Guck mal, das checkt es nicht, null W
Blaues Licht, Tor offen, ach der Fahrstuhl ist jetzt unten
Ok, dann weiß ich was passiert, ich drücke in dem Fahrstuhl auf den Knopf und es wird auf mich aufmerksam und verfolgt mich
So wird es sein
Guckt, guckt
Oder auch nicht
Mal kurz hier durchsuchen, ob hier irgendwas drin ist
Siehste, siehste, war klar
War klar
Gibt es hier irgendwas
Wahrscheinlich nicht so
Da, hallo
What the
Ok, das ist geklitscht
Ich bin irgendwo reingeklitscht
Was zum
Hä
Please
Was war das
Hatte ich zu viel Leben, hat sich das Game gedacht
Ne, nein, zu viel Leben darfst du nicht haben, gibt es nicht
Ich hab mich geduckt
Da war ja auch keine Decke oder so
Ich brauche unbedingt
Ich kann nicht raus
Ich darf nicht raus
Ich wollte eigentlich looten und Zeug aufheben
Ich darf nicht raus, Leute
Ok, das wird jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert
Weil ich vermute mal, dass ich deutlich zu wenig Leben habe für das, was jetzt kommt
Oh, geil
Boah, ey, der Typ hat sich echt Mühe gegeben, der Modder
Die Black Mesa Endzeit-Stimmung
Brennende Waren, brennende Gondel
Hab ich so auch noch keine Mod gesehen
Und auch nicht im originalen Half Life oder den Addons
Ey, vielleicht komme ich jetzt ja mal ans Freie
Das wäre ja auch mal was
Das ist glaube ich von einem Typ, ja
Also der hat wirklich
Sehr viel Arbeit reingesteckt
Leute, ich glaube ich darf jetzt ins Freie jetzt
Ich glaube ich darf jetzt ins Freie
Oder G-Blades, sieht nur so aus
Ok, wir sind oben
Ich habe noch keine Soldaten gesehen, by the way
Das werden die sich sicherlich nicht nehmen lassen
Noch ein paar Soldaten hier ran
Wahrscheinlich kommen jetzt Soldaten
Weil ich so viel Money kriege
Gegen die Soldaten brauchst du deutlich mehr Money als gegen Aliens
Ich kriege Leben, Rüstung
What is happening
Versteck mich mal
Ich stells einfach mal
Weggestellt, next
Oh, Noddles Musik hier
Komm mal, da schießt dem in the ass
Seht ihr das
I get shot up in the ass over here
Ja gut, die Mops sind halt schon
Die Gegner KI ist halt schon nicht mehr so 2021
Die haben sich jetzt schon ziemlich dumm angestellt
Kann man nicht anders sagen
Oh, oh, oh, oh, Shotgun
Achtung, Achtung
Alter, was hältst du aus
Digga, oh, oh, oh
Hab ich Granaten, hab ich
Fuck, okay
Ich hab keine Granaten
Sag mal
Mal ernsthaft
Oh, oh
Sag mal
Was zum
What the fuck
Okay, okay
Überlegen, überlegen
Ich verpiss mich erstmal
Mein Reload ist klatscht
Okay, so
Wie genau krieg ich das jetzt hin
Ach, guck mal, das klatscht durch die Autos durch
Wie soll denn das funktionieren
Ich hab hier auch nix
Ich hab keine Granaten, ich hab nix
Ich hab ne Pistole und Shotguns
Ich muss
Moment, kommt da jetzt noch was
Willst du jetzt einfach warten und mich rettet einer
Wahrscheinlich nicht
Ja, gut
Okay, dann versuch ich jetzt mal
Erstmal die kleinen Dinger zu snipen
Weil die machen Probleme
Okay, nice, nice
Da sind ja noch mehr
Monka, Alter
Wie viel sind denn das
Pepofet in den Bauch schießen
Okay, wir safen mal
Kreisel grind
Jawoll
Outstrafed, outgun, outplayed
Wie noch mehr
Nee, oder
What the fuck
Was ist das für ein Viech
Du hättest ja auch mal früher kommen können
Was ist denn das für ein Viech, das gab es im originalen Half-Life nicht
Ein rausgeschnittener, ein Cut-Gegner aus Half-Life 1
Okay
Weil es sieht richtig gut aus
Also er hat es richtig gut gemacht, aber das passt ja
Wenn es ein Cut-Gegner aus Half-Life 1 ist
Dann haben die den komplett gemodelt schon
Damals beim entwickeln
So
Hopp, hopp
Warum hat der Typ mich nicht einfach vorher reingelassen
Einfach Tür zugemacht, gut ist
Was ist das für ein Bad
Mach ich
Das sperrt mich einfach aus
Was ein Sack
Drecksack
Ah jetzt hat er aber auf der anderen Seite aufgemacht
Okay
Das gibt es ja
Nice
Shotgun Ammo
Jetzt muss auf jeden Fall
Ah man hört es draußen schon schießen
Jetzt gibt es auf jeden Fall gleich Militär
Was ist das für ein Hersteller
Das ist nicht zu entziffern aus dem Pixel
Ah guck mal da sind ja die Soldaten
Richtig cool gemacht
Das ist übrigens das Intro aus Opposing Force
Würde ich mal sagen
Da fliegst du ja mit so einem Ding
Und ich glaube du fliegst auch an der Armee vorbei
Was sie damit eingebaut haben
Mehr Militär als in Deutschland
Naja mehr funktionieren das vielleicht
Mal gucken ob das aufhört
Oder ob der das einfach im Kreis gescriptet hat
Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
Hat er das im Kreis gescriptet oder hört das irgendwann auf
Die Autos hören nicht auf, aber der Panzer hört auf
Und das Sound mit den Jets hört auch nicht auf
Guck mal der Jet fliegt auch immer wieder drüber
Die haben aber ganz schön viele Jets
Ja das ist endlos Schleife gescriptet
Mich würd's nicht wundern wenn der Panzer auch wieder kommt
Wenn der da durch ist und auf die andere Seite geht
Musik ist auch nicht zum Restart gescriptet
Vielleicht sind die auch aus Nordkorea
Die haben nur einen funktionierenden Panzer
Das muss reichen
Aber dafür haben die ganz schön viel Luftwaffe
Aber ich glaube ohne Scheiß
Ich glaube das soll das Intro aus Opposing Force sein
Weil da fliegst du auch an so was vorbei
Hier in so einem Osprey Gun
Peli oder Flugzeug
So Atomic ist ordentlich Money für die Shotgun
Da geht's lang und wo geht's hier lang?
Ah natürlich
Vielleicht Portale aus Port
Leute das wäre ja richtig nice
Hätte der hier noch irgendeine Portalreferenz drin versteckt oder so
Das wäre ja richtig cool
Das wäre richtig cool
Vielleicht hätte der hier noch irgendeine Portalreferenz drin versteckt oder so
Weil Portal und Half-Life spielen ja im gleichen Universum
Und gerade in Portal wird ja auch Black Mesa referenziert
Ich weiß nicht ob es umgedreht ist
Also mir fällt jetzt nichts ein wo in irgendeinem Half-Life
Aperture Science referenziert wird
Aber umgedreht
Was wahrscheinlich schlicht ergreifend daran liegt
Dass Portal nach Half-Life kam
Und man das machen konnte
In Half-Life wusste man das halt noch nicht
Hallo?
Excellent
Ach das ist der Dude von unten
Ok ich will die Stairs benutzen
Wo sind die Stairs?
Ich höre doch Aliens hier
Wo sind die denn?
Ihr hört die doch auch oder?
Ah da oben drin
Ist das nicht das Klo vom Anfang?
Stimmt es gibt doch hier gibt es ein Frauenklo
Oh
Haha
Was ist das?
Leute ich muss mal was testen
Wartet mal ich muss mal was testen
Geht nicht geht nicht
Ich wollte gucken ob er das gemacht hat
Aber der hat sich wirklich
Guck mal mit diesen ganzen Nebenräumen
Übertrieben Mühe gegeben mit dem Mod
Ok Prediction Fahrstuhl stürzt ab
Oder Fahrstuhl passiert
Irgendwas der fährt bestimmt nicht durch
Siehste ich wusste es
Zulull
Äh ausgezulullt
Ich wie ich es gesagt habe
Der Fahrstuhl
Kann es sein das es unverwundbar ist?
Ah da hat eine Panzerung oder so
Oh ne ich habe nicht gespeichert
Ich kann nicht
Ok great
Mal gucken
Die könnten mir ja mal ein bisschen mehr
Waffen geben noch ein paar Granaten
Oder so vielleicht
Das ist ja gerade bisschen äußerst sparsam
Stimmt wo sind eigentlich die diversen Toiletten
Passt mal auf
Es gibt bestimmt einen besseren Weg das Ding zu killen
Wartet mal
Ich gucke mal schnell ob es hier irgendwas gibt
Irgendwelche Schalter oder so
Anscheinend nicht
Ok da hilft nur eins
Frontal
In
Your
Face
Gehst du sofort mit deinen komischen Mücken
Gehst du weg mit deinen Mücken
Gleich haben wir es
Mücken Mücken weg
Wollte mich verarschen
Ich habe mich verarschen
Alter
Oh meine Güte jetzt
Da haben sie aber übertrieben
Mit dem Gegner
Vor allem vorher
Machen sie so
Ja ich bin ja nur ein kleiner Scientist
Der eigentlich nicht großartig was machen kann
Deswegen stellt sich hier nur mit Brecheisen
Und eine Pistole rum
Und da muss ich ein fettes Viech bashen
Da gibt es hier vielleicht noch irgendwie ein bisschen
Lebensenergie
Money gibt es
Aber Leben gibt es nicht
Oh
Armbrust
Gib mir Armbrust
Will die Armbrust haben
Ok ich kann hier bestimmt irgendwie
Durch in die Armbrust stelsen
Jawoll
Das hätte ich machen müssen Leute
Die Dinger sind too hit mit der Armbrust
Ja ja ist klar
Aber wie soll es denn da drauf kommen
Wie soll es denn da drauf kommen
Guck mal hier im Eifer des Gefechts
Checkst du doch nicht
Dass die hier die Armbrust
Dir holen muss
Zum Glück dauert das nicht so lange
Wie Black Mesa, ne ich glaube wir haben noch eine Stunde
Oder wenn es hoch kommt
Ey
Ist ja gut
Versteckt doch nicht
Das finde ich ist nicht gut designed
Dass wirklich in jeder Ecke so ein Ding versteckt ist
Was du gar nicht sehen kannst
Wie das lebt noch
Hallo
Ist das die Hyper Headcrab
Oder was
Armbrust perfekt
Vielleicht hätte ich
Auch ein bisschen mehr gucken müssen
Und hätte dann mehr
Mehr Waffen noch gefunden
Aber das war
Ich glaube das ist der intended
Weg wäre das gewesen
Der intended Weg wäre gewesen
Hier rein rennen
Die Armbrust holen und dann wahrscheinlich hier raus
Snipen oder so
Aber da kommt sie doch hier
Im Eifer des Gefechts nicht drauf
Dass die hinten wenn hier gerade sich das Ding verfolgt
Dass sich Sachen hier sind
Dass du hier hinter mussten da reinkrabbeln
Dann brauch ich auch mehr Prime Subs dafür
Dass mein Hirn ausreicht
Hier kommen wir her
Hier oben ist noch so
Jawoll
Ok jetzt gibt es wenigstens ein bisschen mehr Waffen
Exzellent
Unter dem einen Tor war auch noch der Revolver
Wirklich? Wo? Wo?
Wir haben den Revolver jetzt auch so gekriegt
Aber wo?
Hier war die Armbrust
So hier du meinst da wo es hier lang geht
Ich dachte ich habe noch mehr
Muni übersehen
Kann man eigentlich die
Ironsights?
Hatte das Ding nicht
Also konnte
Irgendwas war mit dem Revolver im Original
Half Life entweder hatte das Ding
Ironsights oder man
Konnte zoomen oder
War das wirklich einfach nur ein poplischer Revolver
Ich glaube man konnte
Zoomen oder
Bam
Voll ins Auge
Evaded
Voll ins Auge jawoll
Jetzt schreckt
So Munition wird ein bisschen knapp
Zumindest Pistol Munition
Wird ein bisschen knapp
Die sind auch fies
Man kriegt auch nur 10 plus Leben
Im Original Half Life hast du laufend
Diese komischen
Aufladestationen und du kannst
Deinen Anzug aufladen und so
Also das hier ist schon eine Ecke schwerer und
Fieser gemacht ja
Hallo
Gordon Freeman Report ist klar
Genau ich habe keinen
Ich habe keinen Environment Suit
Soll ich jetzt hier rumklettern
Ja klar ne
Ok ich weiß was das Game will das Game will dass ich
Komische Half Life
Leiterstells Action mache
Aber wir gehen erstmal aufs Darmklo
Hallo
Wir sind wieder hier
Ok
Doch
So Achtung
So was will das Game jetzt von mir muss ich hoch
Oder muss ich runter
Ok Half Life Leitern
Alter Half Life Leitern
Ist echt so ein Ding
Ok ich glaube
Ich muss runter
Oder
Leiter den Half Life ist echt so ein
Pains Champ Ding
So wenn ich runter gehe
Dann interessiert mich natürlich was oben ist
Und umgedreht
Ok
Anscheinend ist aber unten nichts
Hier hätte man
Mal eine MP5 oder irgendwas
Verstecksorn können
Hier ist nichts
Ok also muss ich doch hoch
Half Life Leitern
Also das ist was
Eine Sache die hat
Ok
Wait a minute
Ach hier muss ich schlagen
Das sind so paar Sachen die haben eigentlich
Die haben in Half Life noch nicht gut funktioniert
Leitern
Leitern war immer so ein Ding
Ist hier durch
Moment
Jetzt bin ich wieder hier
Ok
She baited
Ok nochmal
Also runter muss ich nicht
Ich muss hoch
Da sind wir gerade langgegangen
Da war nichts dann gehen wir hoch
Sei froh dass du nicht das Alpha Leiter
Verhalten hast
Wenn das in der Entwicklung schlecht ist
Sag ich ja gar nichts gegen
Also Half Life und Leitern war immer so ein Ding
Für sich
Also übrigens in Half Life 2 auch nicht wirklich viel besser
Mit den Leitern
Muss ich jetzt hier Jumpen
Nein
Ok
So also Jungs
Haben die einen Plank Messer
Alter
Kann sein, weiß ich nicht
Jetzt
Meine Güte, was muss ich denn hier machen
Moment vorsichtig, vorsichtig, vorsichtig Max
Ha, ich hab's geschafft, pass mal auf
Huge trickshot
Hab ich das jetzt
Ohoho
Hab ich das den Intended
Weg gemacht
Ich glaube nicht oder
Ich glaube das war nicht der Intended
Weg
Ich werd übrigens angeschossen von irgendwo
Da fuck von da unten
Oh mit dem letzten Schuss
Zu fett für die Leiter
Ich hab das nicht den Intended
Weg gemacht oder
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
Nice, MP5
Die aussieht wie ein M16
Aber es ist in der Story eigentlich ein MP5
Jetzt
Jetzt ein bisschen
Shooter, Shootericker hier
So wo geht's lang
Nein
Zu pepo fett für die Leiter
MP5 mit Granatwerfer
Ja klar, gibt's
Zumindest im Half Life Universum
Ja
Jetzt
übertreiben sie es aber
Also jetzt übertreiben sie es aber
Was soll ich noch auf 5mm
Alles killen
Krieg ich noch ein bisschen
Leben vielleicht
Leute soll ich noch mal laden und das ohne
Lebensverlust machen oder hoffen dass es bald
was gibt
Komm ich bleib jetzt, ich lass es jetzt
Easy easy win easy win
Jetzt zu spät
Ich kann mir einfach ein volles Leben
Cheaten im Zweifelsfall
Kein Problem
Gibt's hier noch irgendwas irgendwie
Guck mal da ist grün da gibt's
Ich wollt sagen da ist grün da gibt's bestimmt
noch irgendwas
Aber anscheinend gibt's da
Doch nichts
Aber man kann da bestimmt rein
Es muss da oben je nachdem ein Counter muss
Oh oh oh
Ok
Ich hab keine
Granaten, ich hab nix
Wenn ich Glück hab
Kann ich hier drüber jumpen, jawoll
Passt mal, was kriegen wir hin
Gert schreckt
Türme
Ah
Oh oh oh oh
Der hat einfach die Waffe gewechselt
Beim Aufnehmen, guck hier
Der hat einfach die Waffe gewechselt, ich wollt eigentlich weiter
Ich wollt weiter Kisten klicken
Man muss mal aufpassen
So, aber ich muss sagen
Es ist insofern schon in einer Kategorie
wirklich besser als das originale Half Life
Es ist schwieriger, du hast auch mehr
Also du hast viel knappere
Munition, du hast viel knappere Leben
Jetzt muss man auf Headcrabs aufpassen
Wenn hier jetzt
Headcrabs kommen ist man RIP
Headcrab durch und das Ding fängt an zu schießen
Nein
Warum hält es mehr als
einen doppelten Shotgun Schuss aus
Anzeige
Achtung den snipen wir jetzt
den snipen wir jetzt
Passt mal auf
Was zum
Jawoll
Er sniped, haben wir ihn
M16, wie gesagt
Es ist hier im Reskin der M16
Aber es ist in der original
Storyline, es ist eine MP5 mit Granatwerfer
Nein
Ok
Oh
Die machen mir hier echtes Leben schwer
Ich hab gar nicht genug Money
Um alles hier zu killen
Headcrabs kann ich jetzt nicht
Haben die jetzt eine Rüstung
Die Headcrabs
Max aim
Ich hab die getroffen
Wait a minute
Moment
Gehen die von alleine wieder aus
Ich glaube die gehen
von alleine wieder aus
Wenn sie eigentlich sehen
Ja
Sie sind wieder aus
Easy
Ok
So was möchte denn
das Game von mir
Ich hab ne Headcrab gehört
Wo war denn die Headcrab
Alter
Die Dinger sind so gemein platziert
Den kannst du gar nicht ausweichen
Die, guck mal
Seht ihr die Headcrab
Die ist
in der Leiche
Die ist in der Leiche, dass du sie nicht hitten kannst
Selfmade Ice, Dankeschön für den Sub
Guckts euch an
Ich will an diese Headcrab vorbei
Ah
Headcrab, auf
Nein, nein, nein
Da unten ist ganz schlecht
Ok, nice, erwischt
Ok
Jetzt, jetzt
Weiß ich nicht was ich sagen soll
Meine Güte
Please, lass mich springen
Ok, nice
So
Jetzt haben wir ordentliche Money
Jetzt haben wir gut ausgerüstet
Wo müssen wir jetzt lang
Das ist die nächste Frage
Wo müssen wir lang
Aufgesammelt haben wir alles
Da
Wo gehts lang
Ich hab
Ah, hier guck mal
Knopf
Wo gehts auf
Das
Das riecht mir ganz hart nach Half-Life
Rumspringen rätseln
Ah
Guck mal, da gibt es auch sowas
Nein
Äh
Ok
Wo ist jetzt aufgegangen
Das hat sich gedreht
Das heißt, jetzt ist ein Fahrstuhl weiter unten wahrscheinlich runtergegangen
Hä
Oh, huge skills
Habt ihr das gesehen, den Jump
Ich bin raus
So, guck mal
Hat sich hier was bewegt
Ja, da
Seht ihr es
Oder
Ich bin mir da jetzt echt nicht sicher
Hat er sich bewegt
Oder war er vorher schon
Ich denke auch, dass der sich bewegt hat
Oh nein, Half-Life Leitern
Come on
Ne, oder
Ah, wir haben es geschafft
Oh, lila
Copper Pride Level
Kommt jetzt
Die Dinger hacken einen übrigens kaputt, wenn man vorsieht
Das heißt, die Dinger
Die Dinger
Die Dinger hacken einen übrigens kaputt, wenn man vor sie läuft
Ich versuche euch das mal zu zeigen
Das ist jetzt Absicht, Leute
Schreckt
Aufpassen
Flatsch, Flatsch, Flatsch
Muss klatschen, Leute
Wie genau erwartet das Spiel von mir, dass ich das durchkomme
Ah, Evaded
Okay
Schleichstelz
Gute Toni
Ich hab gehört, der Toni ist mittlerweile sogar verheiratet
Da, da, da
Er ist mittlerweile sogar verheiratet
Der Offenbacher Toni
Ohne Spaß, Leute
Ohne Spaß
Okay, okay
Wie genau erwartet das Game von mir, dass ich hier durchkomme
Ohne irgendwas zu berühren
Einfach, einfach
Die Dinger hacken sogar
Das fällt mir auch jetzt zum ersten Mal auf
Es gibt immer wieder Sachen, die den Half-Life echt neu entdeckt
Diese Dinger hacken auch nach
Ähm
Random
Crap
Rumpe, drei Monate
Ja, das macht übels Bock
Ich fürchte nur, es ist gleich vorbei
Ich dachte es sind Nades, das ist ein Skelett
Eins, zwei, drei, vier
Guck mal, die hacken auch nach diesen komischen
Innereien
Das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen vorher
Was liegt denn da drauf?
Eins, zwei, drei, vier
Sind die nicht
Soundanfällig?
Ich glaube, die sind berührungsanfällig und
Soundanfällig und jetzt schnell durch
Hey
Das ist der Sicherheitsmann, den wir finden müssen
Laut
Laut Main Quest müssen wir den Sicherheitsmann finden
Hier, das funktioniert nicht
Jetzt muss ich irgendwie zum Sicherheitsmann kommen
By the way, warum habe ich eigentlich so als
Big brain scientist
Keine Zugangscodes
Was ist denn das?
Äh, okay
Der G-Mann
Was jetzt?
Monarches
WTF
Was passiert?
Alles klar
Gleich geht es weiter in Half Life 2
Wir machen noch einétaisch
Ist das so ein Ding was mich heilt?
Nein.
Doch!
Das ist so ein Ding was mich heilt.
Excellent!
Leute, HotTube Stream!
Gleich mal Kategorie umstellen.
Ich mach mal kurz die passende Sounduntermalung noch an.
Ich hoffe man hört's.
Ok ich mach den Sound wieder aus.
Ne hört man nicht!
Ich hab Wassergeplätscher angemacht.
Good Job!
Ein Security Mann!
Sehr gut!
Komm mit!
Äh Moment, wo müssen wir jetzt überhaupt mit dem Typ langen?
Hier?
Warum nennt man das HotTube?
Ja, weil...
Weil huge English Skills in my homeland Baden-Württemberg we say we are all sitting in one boat.
Ich weiß wenn uns unsere Anführer schon vormachen ne?
Guck mal da war noch ein Shotgun Ammo.
Kommste?
Wo ist er hin?
Was?
Warte mal.
Lass mich mal was ausprobieren.
Was passiert?
Ok.
Daran hat er gedacht.
Ich glaube wir haben's geklitscht.
Ich glaub wir haben's geklitscht kurzzeitig.
Auf, ich will Ammo sparen, gibs ihn!
Alter was denn das für ein Wachmann!
Was denn das für ein Kacknoob!
Wir schießen den einfach in den Sack.
Jetzt hab ich keine Muni gespart.
Nur weil du nix kannst, Alter!
Digga fühl ich gar net!
Falls man das so sagt heute, ihr wisst ich bin da nicht so aufgelaufen, ich bin zu alt
für sowas.
Da ist, ne, die Reifer mit seiner Magne um die Headcrabs weg bashed.
Ja du machst das schon, mach weiter.
Der hat wenigstens ein bisschen Firepower, der Typ.
Ich frag mich ob wir noch mal gegen Soldaten kämpfen müssen, wussten wir bisher noch
gar nicht.
What?
Oh!
Achtung!
Nate!
Jawoll!
Get schreckt!
Ok, das lass ich dich machen.
Easy Wachmann, easy life.
So muss das sein.
Hat alles für uns geklärt, der Typ, der hat ja unendlich Schuss.
Kann er dich erschießen?
Ey, ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ob wenn man in die Sicht rennt, ob der einem
Damage machen kann.
Die leben!
Die leben, 100%.
Ey, die stehen gleich auf.
Ich hab's so im Gefühl.
Komm mit.
Ähm, hier?
Ach guck mal da ist so ein Ding, so ein Schieber aus der Kammer.
What the?
Es lebt noch, guckt's euch an.
Kann man das killen?
Wartet mal, kann man das killen?
Nein.
Geht nicht.
Ok, wo sind wir?
Ah, da ist ne Shotgun, ich brauch ne Shotgun, please, mach auf.
Ich glaub, der hat da nix für, das aufzumachen.
Ok, weiter.
Mitkommen?
Nein, du sollst nicht hier warten.
Komm her.
Hier.
Aufmachen.
Aufmachen, looten.
Diese, diese Wachmänner gab's im Original nicht hier.
Also Wachmann mit, mit, äh, environment suit und Magnum, gab's nicht.
Das hat der wahrscheinlich für den Mod gemacht, oder aber, das gab es in irgendeiner Extension,
an die ich mich jetzt nicht erinnern kann.
Guck mal da.
Da hätte man wahrscheinlich vor, Moment, man kann hier rein?
Wait a minute.
Wo geht's denn hier lang?
MonkaS?
Na klar, na klar.
Granaten?
Ich glaub, hier hätte ich vorher schon hingekonnt, in diesen Raum.
Ich glaub, ich geh gerade rückwärts.
Ah, Magnum-Money, die kann man immer gebrauchen.
Schau, hinter mir, boah, otte, das war doch eben noch nicht da, aber hinter mir spawnen
ich mal ernsthaft.
Das ist wirklich fies, das macht man nicht sowas.
Guck mal da.
Okay, hier musste ich doch lang.
Hey, das ist dieses große Ding, was mich verfolgt.
Okay, äh, ich dachte, hier spawnen jetzt Gegner, jetzt, okay, jetzt müssen wir, jetzt müssen
wir ein paar Soldaten bekämpfen, 100%, muss hier irgendwann mal kommen.
MonkaW, wir snipen einfach alles weg, 360, NoScope, 360, NoScope, easy, und da kommen
jetzt Assassins?
Es kommen Assassins, in your face, Alter, stimmt, die Assassins gab's ja auch noch.
Die, ich, ich snipet die jetzt einfach, schrägt, die müssen geschnipet werden, Leute, ah,
die machen zu viel Damage, die machen zu viel Damage, okay, quait, bam, habt ihr den Flick
gesehen, Leute, so, war's das?
Keiner F, Hehe.
Äh, alles klar?
alles klar excellent die assassins sind grills ja korrekt das habt ihr richtig erkannt chat
das sind grill assassins ob es hotter grills sind weiß ich nicht so genau sieht man ja nicht
sportlich sind sie ja ok das stimmt das stimmt so gibt es hier noch irgendwas zu looten
nope no pass dann geht es jetzt höchstwahrscheinlich hier unten irgendwo lang
musik übertreibt wieder mal gucken ob wir das schaffen wobei ich kill die einfach müssen
ich übertreiben ok jetzt kommt wieder irgendwas was mich schocken soll ich sag es euch garantiert
irgendwas soll mich jetzt wieder schocken oder auch nicht hätte gedacht die geht es lang
nope no pass an die musik ist vorbei excellent die monka s musik ist vorbei
chat wo geht es lang wo geht es lang ach da ist eine leiter half life please
also die dinger sind teilweise wirklich schwierig zu sehen natürlich chat ich weiß ihr habt
sicherlich schon beim ersten mal gesehen und nur weil ich gesagt habe kein backseat gaming
habt ihr nichts gesagt damage machen die dann erst mal aufs klo setzen erst mal aufs klo
setzen nachladen nimmt man damage wenn man da rein läuft was das
kann man das kaputt was was das warum
die haben das ding gekillt war das nicht das was mich verfolgt hat die ganze zeit
das sind die neuen moten toiletten auf japan dachte eigentlich die funktionieren mit wasser
aber wer weiß also bei den japanern bist du dir nie sicher vielleicht haben die neuerdings
auch so ein ding was dir den bobs ab tentakelt dazu kann man nur sagen man weiß da nie genau
die haben somit tentakel ich habe eine granate wasted schreckt ich habe eine granate wasted
das ding ist nicht verreckt tail die sehen wieder nix highly trained professionals hier
seht ihr es huge elite soldaten die nix mitkriegen hallo hallo jungs was geht ich die big brains die
haben noch nicht primes abt da reicht der IQ einfach nicht aus bei den zwei gibt es hier noch was jawoll
hier war ich doch gerade schon ok hier ist vielleicht noch ein bisschen was drin und
soll ich weitere luftschachtstelle machen please no no god please no genug luftschachtstelle oder
kann ich oder kann ich hier drumherum stellen sie sind weg ist einfach weg hier hat es aber
ganz schön zerlegt hier hallo was da los pogas waffe unendlich munitionsstelle so muss es sein
ok ich muss doch luftschachtstelle machen leute ich sag es euch geht nicht anders
es gehen will von mir die luftschachtstelle jetzt kann ich endlich headcrabs bashen ohne
dass ich sinnlos munition verschwenden muss und auch getter und sowas bäbä bäbä bäbä jawoll
Moment hier war ich schon, jetzt bin ich, ich lost, komplett lost, hier muss ich schon
gewesen sein sonst wären hier keine toten headcrabs, komplett lost leute, muss ich vielleicht
hier was machen, den schieben oder so, okay was muss ich machen, ich habe keine ahnung,
hier komme ich her, hier komme ich her, okay okay ich bin komplett, komplett lost,
lass mal gucken, immerhin so kompliziert kann es nicht sein, wir müssen jetzt hier
durchstelzen und jetzt muss es ja irgendwo raus gehen, was ist denn jetzt, da ist auch
nichts, ich meine hier kann es ja jetzt nix mehr sein, security lock is engaged, okay
heißt, heißt was genau, hier ist der raum wo ich eben gefightet habe, okay leute ich
habe kein blassen shimmer, absolute any cuties in chat, wir haben ganz ganz viele cuties,
richtiger, richtig cuter chat, der wachmann hat eine tür aufgemacht, okay game, game
was willst du von mir, was willst du von mir spiel, hier drin, ich höre was schießen,
geht hier jetzt was, ne hier bin ich ja vorhin durchgestelzt, aber hier gibt es noch ein
paar nades optimal, ich mein lüftungsschacht stelzen muss ich nicht machen, da komme ich
her, oder will mich das spiel gebaten, oder gebatet mich das game und ich komme hier doch
nicht her, weil hier tote headcrabs sind, doch hier bin ich vorhin lang, hier bin ich
schon, okay ich gehe jetzt noch mal runter, ich habe echt keinen plan wo ich hin muss,
vielleicht ging es ja doch unten weiter, wachmann, warte mal, sag ernsthaft ich muss da gar nicht
lang oder wie, ich wusste da gar nicht lang, ich wusste da gar nicht lang, oh man ich hätte
einfach hier unten weiter gemusst, okay jetzt müssen wir soldaten bashen, moment, moment,
moment, mal kurz hier checken, jawoll, schreckt, ja das ist jetzt, okay das war jetzt ein bisschen
komisch gemacht, ich dachte die ganze zeit ich muss ja oben langen, weil es irgendwie
so aussah auch mit dem alien durch die tür, dabei muss ich hier unten langen, aber richtig
nice half life level design, so war das im original auch, oh, ist da ein loch, nein,
einfach nur ein glas was man nicht sieht, sag mal seid ihr blind, du seid ihr blind,
absolut nicht agil genug hier, absolut nicht agil genug, hier weiter, auf wachmann, komm
her, wachmann, wachmann, lauf, move, hm, da jetzt, ja, ja, mach auf, wie, du kannst
dich aufmachen, hier hatten wir doch vorher den fight, das sieht aber anders aus, hier
kommt bestimmt noch ein fight jetzt, aufmachen blitz, gut, so jetzt haben wir unsere quest
erledigt, lang kann das nicht, lol, jebaited, richtig hart jebaited, da kann ich nur sagen,
ok, weiter gehts, ja, und tschüss, wie, kommst du doch nicht mit, naja, der hat keinen
Bock, ok, wachmann, ist das klopapier, ist das low res klopapier, seh ich das richtig,
man kann das sogar kaputt machen, die zukunft ist jetzt, 1998 schon da gewesen, breakable
klopapier, revolution, ja, ok, wo genau gehts lang, das game ist mir gerade ein bisschen
zufällig, ach da, gehts jetzt raus, gehts jetzt raus, ne oder, wie jetzt, wo gehts denn
jetzt lang, das game hat mich doch die ganze zeit hierher geführt, gibt es einen lüftung
schacht, hab ich den lüftung schacht übersehen, warte mal ist hier ein lüftung schacht, aah,
meine güde, half life stels, es ist aber gut gemacht, weil es ist wirklich im sinne
so des originals, da war das ja auch so wir oftmals, ok, nein, no pass, no pass, no pass,
no pass, no pass, no pass, lass mich raus, raus, aah, aah, fuck, ok, ich weiß jetzt
nicht, es ist, es ist insofern ganz gut gemacht, dass grün immer, ich hatte die texturen vergessen,
oder, dass grün immer gleich hier gehts lang ist, das finde ich schonmal gut, ok, hier
müssen wir auf jeden fall nicht lang, bleibt ja nur hier, der typ ist dead, kipp, ok, es
geht musik an, es passiert irgendwas, da spawnet jetzt was, da spawnen jetzt dinger, die musik
fängt schon an, da kommt jetzt irgendwas, oh, jetzt kommen militär angestellte, nein,
freeman ist nicht down, freeman ist gar nicht hier, ihr kacknoobs, hallo, hallo ihr kacknoobs,
hallo, ja das alien bestiets, oder die machen sich jetzt gegenseitig platt, ok, ich save
kurz und ich verpiss mich jetzt hier ganz schnell während die kämpfen, frage ist nur,
Frage ist nur, wohin?
Wohin, wohin?
Wait a minute, da war was im Boden, das war jetzt so Zufall, dass ich da rein bin.
Ich muss wahrscheinlich wirklich hier rein.
Na gut, ich sag nix, passt schon. Geht's da hinten noch weiter? Oh, secret, secret.
Shotgun-Ammo, Shotgun-Ammo, Shotgun-Ammo. Ach, da hätte man auch reingekonnt.
Es ist grünes Licht, und was tut es? Es leuchtet grün.
Ja klar, was damage?
Pass mal auf, die werden geschnallt.
Bäm, nicht sehr fair, nicht fair, ich trick's euch einfach aus, Massive-Trick-Sore.
Nee, ich glaub die lassen sich nicht austricksen.
Okay, 360 Northscope. Alter, die machen fucking viel Damage. Moment, das muss man auch mit weniger Damage hinkriegen.
Okay, damit bin ich zufrieden, damit bin ich zufrieden, 50, okay.
Äh, da komm ich hier drüber durch. Wenn ich das auslöse, was passiert dann überhaupt? Ah, Turrets. Dann...
Dann stellst du mir doch mal an die Turrets vorbei, würde ich sagen.
Ein paar mehr auslösen kommt in den Rickroll.
Never gonna give you up, ich weiß übrigens nicht wie es weiter geht. Kennt jemand die Lyrics?
Never gonna give you up, never gonna let you down, genau. Die Dinger halten mega viel aus, so viel haben die im Original nicht ausgehalten.
Oh, ich hab Pfeile gekriegt für meine 360 Quickscope Armbrust.
Okay, next. Äh, haben die eine Mario Mütze auf? Nee, sah so aus. In der S, in der S.
Vielleicht war das gar keine so gute Idee, die anzuschießen. Bam, da ist er down. Oder auch nicht. Nee, der ist gar nicht down.
Die machen da den Kreiselgrind unten. Ja, Hot Tube, genau. Können die mal sterben, please? Sterben, please?
Das ist jetzt übrigens für mich richtiger MonkaS-Moment. Ihr wisst, dass ich tiefes Wasser nicht mag. Und dann auch tiefes Wasser mit Fischen drinne.
Was machen die denn da? Könnt ihr euch mal zeigen, dass ich euch bashen kann, bitte? Hört mich auf zu tube-baden.
Ist der down? Ich glaub, einer ist down. Die bewegen sich halt auch so ab. Nein, ist nicht nur einer down.
Okay, ich glaube, es war keine so gute Idee, die anzuschießen.
Okay, die sterben nicht. Das war keine gute Idee, die anzuschießen. Ich muss, glaube ich, nochmal laden. Ich treff die auch nicht.
Okay, wir probieren das mal anders. Ganz schlecht. Ganz schlecht. Ganz schlecht.
Okay.
Hab ich's geschafft? Hab ich's geschafft? Outmoved? Outbaded? Verspeichern? Jawoll.
Da unten war bestimmt noch irgendwelche Secrets versteckt, aber weißt du was? Scheiß drauf.
Das schreit nach Endkampf. So viel Zeugs hier. X, X. Irgendwie hab ich das Gefühl, ich sollte die Türme besser hier lassen.
Aha, neust. She baited. She baited. Was war denn das? Okay, vielleicht lass ich die Türme doch nicht hier.
Eine Handgranate. Suckernate. Was ist das für ein Half-Life-Mod? Echoes heißt das. Das spielt man aus der Sicht von einem Scientist.
Turm, krieg dich ein. Turm, aufhören. Aufhören, Turm. Ich weiß was, wir schießen jetzt um die Ecke an.
Man kann die baiten. Das wusste ich ja noch gar nicht. Man kann die Türme baiten mit so einer Mücke. Habt ihr das gerade gesehen?
Das ist ja Poggers. Guck mal. Guck mal. Guck mal, die schießen auf die Mücken.
Leute, man lernt echt nie aus. Man lernt nie aus in dem Game. Das wusste ich nicht, dass man die Türme mit Mücken baiten kann.
Cool. Sehr, sehr nice. Wirklich. Sehr nice. Ach, das war ein Minen. Das war einfach nur Trigger-Dinger.
So, wir sind voll. Pulle. Alles Hammer. Hier Granatenhammer, Munihammer. Jetzt können wir Soldatenbashing gehen.
Schon wieder hier. Wie oft wollen wir doch hier langlaufen? Oh, Massive-Animation vom Tank.
Kannst du die aufnehmen? Nice. Jetzt haben die richtig gut gemacht. Voll Endzeit-Stimmung jetzt hier.
Ja, Turm. Du machst das schon. Wir sparen ein bisschen Muni und ballern mit den Mücken drauf.
Was ich mich übrigens immer gefragt habe ist, warum die Mücken auf die Aliens reagieren.
Weil eigentlich sollten das ja Friendlies sein und die Mücken sollten nicht auf die Aliens gehen. In meiner Half-Life-Lore-Vorstellung.
Okay, Damage macht das nicht wirklich, oder? Hallo? Sterben? Blitz? Okay, das hält ganz schön viel aus, das Ding.
Okay. Ich weiß, dass ich hier herkomme. Ich wollte nur mal... Nee, da gibt es keinen anderen Weg.
Nice. 75%. Okay, jetzt sind wir voll stockt. Voll. Jetzt haben wir noch nicht mal zu wenig Muni. Jetzt haben wir alles maxed.
Moment, haben wir den gebashed damit? Oh. Schreckt. So, jetzt Chibaiten wir. Mal gucken, ob wir um die Ecke schießen können.
Pass mal auf. Pass mal auf. Pass mal auf. Chibaiten. Au. Nee, nee, nee. So nicht. So nicht. Okay. Mal gucken, ob man den Fuß snipen kann.
Auch nicht. Hallo. Guck mal, wie geil. Wie die sich alle selbst bashen. Kompletter Self-Own. Die ollen sich alle. Komm mal hier. Die ollen sich alle selbst.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich muss aufpassen, dass ich mich nicht auch selbst owne.
Oh Gott, Chibaitet. Shotgun Ammo. Nice. Excellent. So, weiter. Oh. Moment, Sniper, Sniper, Sniper, Sniper, Sniper, Sniper.
Seht, seht ihr da irgendwas, was man snipen kann? Ich probier's jetzt einfach mal.
Ich glaub, das funktioniert so nicht. Ach, da vorne. Wo zum? Okay, nee. Ich glaube, die sind nicht zum Killen gedacht.
Ich glaube, die kann's nicht machen. Auf die Minen schießen? Wo ist denn da eine Mine? Nee, wir müssen stelzen. Wir müssen hier, wir müssen hier Anschleichung stelzen machen.
Ich hab gedacht, ich hab noch ne Granate. Game? Hallo? Warum geht das Game Red einfach raus? Massive Chibaitet. Okay, pass mal auf, pass mal auf.
Oh, oh. Hi. Falscher Knorp. Okay, jetzt aber, jetzt aber. Massive Stels, Massive Stels. Bam. Jawoll. Alles weg.
Okay, Moment. Zum Glück ist die Kiste noch nicht da. Ich muss die Kiste da reinschieben, Leute.
Kistenphysik. Alter Kistenphysik, hör auf. Mensch.
Ist das den hier in Ernst? Hallo? Was ist das für ne Genauigkeit? Okay, das können sie sogar erklären. Ich mein, das ist ein Scientist, der ist nicht so gut da drin.
Wobei, warum ist Gordon Freeman eigentlich so gut da drin? Okay. Kommen die sich nicht verarscht vor?
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr sitzt an so nem MG-Geschütz, ne? Stellt euch mal vor, ihr sitzt an so nem MG-Geschütz und es kommt einer mit ner Kiste auf euch zugeschoben.
Bleibt ihr dann einfach hinter dem MG-Geschütz sitzen und macht nix? Okay, mal gucken, ob wir die jetzt wenigstens so bashen. Nein.
Mal gucken, ob man die wenigstens so bashen kann. Alter, please.
Nee, die kann man nicht bashen, okay. Da nicht. Dann lassen wir die jetzt einfach da. Wo sind die Headcrabs? Wo sind die Headcrabs? Ich hab Headcrabs gehört.
Okay, Granaten. Wir brauchen wahrscheinlich einfach Granaten. Guck mal. Ja, ist ja meine Güte. Wir müssen die mit Granaten killen.
Wenn hier so viele Granaten sind, dann will das Game von uns, dass wir die mit Handgranaten killen. Pass mal auf. Das will das Game von uns jetzt.
Wisst ihr? Obvious. Easy clap. So, da haben wir's. Irgendwas piepst hier noch. Moment, was ist hier los?
Ist da gerade noch was? Noch ein Turret oder so? Hat sich gerade wie ein Turret angehört. So eine Decke vielleicht.
Sag mal, hab ich den nicht getroffen oder war einfach ppega damage? Ich glaub, ich hab den nicht getroffen. Zu noobig.
Was zum Geier macht das... Ey Leute, entweder ist Boomer schlafen angesagt. Fuck man. Jetzt wird's aber... Okay, der wird gesniped. Easy snipe. Ich sag's euch. Easy snipe.
Zack. Snipe. Wo ist mein Crosshair? Mein Crosshair ist weg.
Okay. Nice. Nice. Nice. Shotgun raus und in your face. In your face.
Was die für'n Damage fahren. Meine Güte. Okay, das ist ja echt die normale gerade. Und jetzt sprengen die sich auch noch selbst in die Luft.
Das ist ja... Cover my ass.
Warum mehrt ihr daubend sich die Typen? Guckt euch das mal an. Was soll denn das? Kommt's ja fast. Vollkott 4 Multiplayer.
Last stand. Fuck you, last stand. Da stellts klauen, wusste's schon. Und warum zum... Alter, das Game ist gegen mich gerade. Ich krieg Anfälle.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir noch irgendwelche Sentry Guns wegschneiden. Oder die Sentry Guns müssen wir glaub ich gar nicht wegschneiden.
Wir können die doch ablenken, haben wir doch eben gelernt. Nice.
Guck, die Dinger, die gehen auf die Mücken. Das ist ja geil. Das ist wirklich, ohne Scheiß, das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen.
Battlefield 3 Aim brauch ich hier nicht. Ich hab's sau schnell eingestellt. Guckt euch das mal an.
Das sind, keine Ahnung, 3 cm Battlefield 60 oder so. Ist halt angenehm zu spielen einfach nur mit Handgelenken ohne sich kaum zu bewegen.
Fast 800. Jetzt weiter. Wie lang geht denn das noch? Ich hab eigentlich gehofft wir kriegen das heute fertig.
Klopf, klopf, klopf, klopf, klopf. Was denn das? Was genau? Ah, jetzt kommen die Dinger. Das ist auch eine eigene Waffe.
Die haben ihm grad ab in die Ass würde ich sagen. Oh nein, jetzt kommen noch mehr von den Viechern, please. Die sacken richtig.
Man konnte die glaube ich ganz gut, ganz gut nahkampfen. Meine Güte. Die habe ich schon gehasst im Original, ich sag's euch.
Ich glaub die kommen wenn man über die Leichen läuft, kann das sein? Oh nein, come on. Die explodieren übrigens nach einer Zeit. Man muss einfach nur abwarten.
Kann man die auto aimen mit dem Ding? Ah, man kann die auto aimen. Das ist halt auch cool. Die Waffen haben alle irgendeinen Sinn.
Das ist richtig geil. Das ist doch Poggers oder? Sowas find ich geil. Die Waffe da fehlen irgendwie ein paar Animationen.
Top, hier geht's weiter, by the way. Hallo? Sterben, please. Nimm mir die Runde Half-Life Multiplayer. Nee, eher nicht.
Okay, wenn's hier oben weiter geht, wovon ich ausgehe, wo geht's dann hier um die Ecke weiter? Ich berühr euch nicht Leute, ich berühr euch nicht. Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, lass mich in Ruhe.
Oh, Knoss. Gibt's hier noch irgendwas? Nope, no pass. Alter, was ist das denn? Was macht denn das Game manchmal?
Ach, guck mal. Das Minima ist sich ganz merkwürdig. Ach, guck mal, jetzt krieg ich auch die Dinger. Nice. Die sind huge.
Also ich hab die schon im Original gehasst, diese kleinen Dinger, aber benutzen ist geil. Mehr Zeugs, jawoll. Kann man immer gebrauchen. Mehr Muni.
Ich muss sagen, die haben eine richtig gute, also mit dem Mod haben sie ein richtig gutes Zwischending gefunden. Am Anfang so ein bisschen Horror-Survival-Stellz und jetzt halt in your face, bam.
Okay Leute, ich glaub wir müssen keine Muni mehr sparen. Ich glaub das ist vorbei mit Muni sparen.
Und die sparen es vorbei. Leute, wenn es noch, hat es jemand schon gespielt und weiß wie lange es noch geht? Weil eigentlich müsste ich jetzt off. What the? Ja, äußerst fair.
Äußerst fair, sparen hinter mir. Moment, wir sind am Anfang. Seht ihr das? Wir sind wieder am Anfang. Das ist da wo der Typ vorhin oben drauf geschlafen hat.
Könnt ihr euch da noch am Anfang dran erinnern? Das ist wo ich hier ganz am Anfang raufgesprungen bin. Wo jeder Typ gelegen hat und hat geschlafen.
Das ist ganz, okay dann kann es nicht mehr lange dauern. Das muss dann ziemlich am Ende sein jetzt. Ja. Oder aber die haben das recycelt, die Area.
Okay. Kommt ihr um die Ecke? Kommt her, kommt her. Jawoll, kommt her. Aha.
Okay, die sind nicht ohne. Die machen echt ordentlich Damage. So, erstmal reload. Was haben wir alles gebraucht? Haben wir Pfeile gebraucht? Haben wir Magnum Muni gebraucht? Nope, no poss.
Eigentlich fehlt uns nur noch der Raketenwerfer. Dann haben wir das komplette. Ach Quatsch, ne uns fehlen auch die ganzen Experimental Weapons. Aber die werden wir wahrscheinlich in dem Mod nicht kriegen.
Um, um, um die Ecke, um die Ecke stellst du? Fuck, fuck, fuck. Ah, you got jebaited.
Was? Komm her. Ha, null. Endlich mal, dass man die Minen auch braucht. Die hat man im Original Half Life auch so selten gebraucht.
Richtig cool gemacht. Ja, ich bin da echt begeistert von, also ich weiß nicht, ob es der Mod des Jahres 2018 geworden ist. Es war auf jeden Fall Top 3. Hat er aber auch definitiv verdient. Wirklich geil.
Das hier vielleicht platt machen? Ha, ich wusste es. Kann man hier aufmachen irgendwo? Irgendwo Tür aufmachen?
Ja gut, dass das da in Areal 85 drauf steht. Was passiert jetzt?
Okay. Kommt her. Kommt her. Kommt her. Auf.
Der G-Man war auch schon ein paar Mal am Start, ja. Ich glaube, die können da nicht durch. Ich glaube, die können nicht durch.
Das Zoom Incense ist ganz merkwürdig. Moment, da ist ein LMG. Das ist ein LMG, Leute. Das ist ein LMG. LMG legit.
LMG legit. Das kannst du aber knicken.
LMG legit.
Alter, was passiert hier? Ah, Xen-Fiescher. Okay, ich muss alles bashen. Ich muss alles bashen. Alles bashen.
Huge bash. Okay. Wie sieht es aus? Über mir, über mir, Nordertz. Stapfwurz.
Ich könnte noch ein paar Granaten gebrauen jetzt. Oh, das sind so fette. Den muss man übrigens in den Bauch snipen und nicht hier.
Oder in den Arm. In den Arm geht es, glaube ich, auch. Oder auch nicht. Schreck. In den Arm. So, zweiten noch. Einfach in den Arm snipen. Easy.
Hatten wir da noch irgendein Lebensding? Gab es hier noch irgendwas zum Aufladen? Ah, ein bisschen noch.
Okay, nice, nice. Oh. Give Moon. Ach, den snipen wir wieder. Zum Glück sind sie so dumm.
Zum Glück sind die so massivst, massivst pepega, die Gegner. Gehen die Schildautomaten nicht? Nein, die Schildautomaten gehen nicht.
Weil ich kein, ich habe ja kein environment suit an. Okay, okay. Wo geht es raus? Nice. Alles auffüllen. Jawoll.
Vor allem, ich bin ja ein Scientist. Ganz schön geiles Military Training der Scientist. So wie der hier abgeht.
Perfekt.
Hier ist nichts. Ah, Headcrab, Headcrab, Headcrab. Ich glaube, hier habe ich voll. Der Heelautomat ist ziemlich catjam. Ja. Der Heelautomat ist hier so eines der, glaube, neben den Ansagen von dem Suit, eines der ikonischsten Dinger.
Moment, Sequence 8. Wie viel Sequence hat das Ding? Half Life Echoes Sequence. Sequences.
Sequence.
Sequence. Ich muss wissen, wie lange das noch geht. Ich habe nicht noch das. Gibt es neuen?
Leute, das kann ich heute nicht mal durchspielen. Das müssen wir morgen fertig machen. Es gibt noch zwei Levels, die wir spielen müssen. Das geht zu lange heute.
Setka, ich weiß, Setka, wir machen gleich morgen, wenn ich mit der Arbeit fertig bin, mal weiter. Sobald ich mit der Arbeit fertig bin, mal weiter, Leute. Direkt, wenn ich fertig bin.
Kopfgrabbe. Dann Kopfgrabt mal ein bisschen. Ich hoffe, euch hat es trotzdem gefallen. War auf jeden Fall ein nicer Stream.
Richtig, richtig geiler Mod. Richtig massiv geiler Mod. Wann wäre es denn morgen ungefähr? Ja, gut nach der Arbeit, denn nach der Arbeit gehe ich noch kurz ein bisschen Sport machen.
Das heißt so wahrscheinlich um, ja, wahrscheinlich so um 17 Uhr, denke ich mal. 17, vielleicht 18 Uhr. Sport Keg Weight. Ich weiß, Leute. Ich weiß. Richtig schränt.
Leute, wir sehen uns morgen. Machts gut. Schön, dass ihr alle dabei gewesen seid. Ich hoffe, euch hat der Mod auch so gut gefallen wie mir bis jetzt. Bis denn. Machts gut. See you.